Und leute sind früher als sonst und nichts gemacht ich habe halbe tasse tee getrunken trostbrot gessen
Also kann durchaus sein dass ich beim laufe des streams wegen die zehn minuten ab muss aufs klo oder
Machen jetzt acht linux updates
Weil bleeding edge 8 spiele
Der f programmer ist auch am start
Woher wusstest du eigentlich um 8 uhr 51 dass ich schon den chat lese oder war das einfach auf gut glück
Jetzt stellst
Bist du bist du schon drin ja wie es geht und es war alles
nur vier packages die geupdatet wurden
Woher wusstest du das mit der ak
Tja
Das ist echt eine gute frage
Ich würde mal sagen gut gerade
Ne ich habe kein update gemacht vorher
Aber er f programmer wenn du so gut bescheid weißt was gibt
Es heute bei mir zu essen ja so news gibt es ja laufend öfters
Nudel mit lachs ist falsch und gibt es das halbe hähnchen von gestern
Da habe ich gelesen ja in italien auch irgendwo in italien muss jetzt irgendein
Denn in den su in eine suv fahrerin in italien muss jetzt irgendwie ein paar jahre in die psychiatrie
weil sie auch in
Eine fußgänger gruppe oder so absichtlich gefahren ist ganz wird
Oh, was ist hier und mein
Maus sharing mit der anderen in der stadt richtig war
okay ist
kannst ja
Ganz ja noch gucken ist ja noch alles da mach lieber deine rpg session
ich habe übrigens
Die musik ländlosschleife dass man hier lieber irgendwas
Anderes anmachen
ist vielleicht ein bisschen bisschen laut
ja
Mache ich
Ich gehe eigentlich fast fast jeden tag
Außer es war tag davor zu anstrengen da mache ich war auch ab und zu mal tag pause aber das ist unregelmäßig nehmen der gleiche tag
Ja
Samstag oder sonntag ist meistens auch der tag wo ich eine längere runde laufen die also länger heißt irgendwie so eine stunde
20 oder so
Das ist heute laut meinem plan gar nicht dran
Weil gestern auch so semi lang schon war also fahrrad ist heute nix fahrrad ist zu viel zu viel
Zu großes scheiß wetter für fahrrad was was gucken
Was ist das fazit mit dem neuen rad eigentlich was meinst du
ob mir das gefällt oder
Weil du weißt doch schon alles
Also
Also was ist das fazit
Nach so sechs monaten also ich muss sagen
zweimal elf
Schaltung
Gefällt mir tatsächlich besser als einmal 11
Ich dachte eigentlich einmal elf ist nicer
weil
Das cleaner aussieht und weniger
mechanische
Sachen gibt und so was
Aber ist es nicht das macht eigentlich kaum probleme mit dem umwerfer
Und man hat einfach eine viel größere range
Also insofern finde ich das eigentlich besser ich muss sagen also mir gefällt das rad besser als das alte das ist das fazit
so
ab jetzt habe ich gemacht
Reboot habe ich auch schon übrigens welt fünf ist offiziell released habe ich vorhin gelesen
Mich release kandidat offiziell
released
Muss wird demnächst wieder front end stellt machen
14 stunden
aber nicht rippen in rast
Also so unter dem strich muss man sagen
Hat sich der unfall tatsächlich ein bisschen gelohnt mir ist nichts passiert bei das schon mal das wichtigste und
ich habe jetzt quasi zwei verwendete
fahrräder das eine fahrrad ist ja rein wirtschaftlich gesehen total schaden ein
total schaden was aber nicht heißt dass ich das nicht auf dem heimtrainer
weiterfahren kann weil wenn das auseinanderbricht auf
heimtrainer juckt mich ja nicht und jetzt habe ich zwei habe ich quasi
zweimal das gleiche fahrrad nur einmal mit 2 x 11 und mit 1 x 11 schaltung und
bei meinem neuen habe ich ja hinten noch ein bisschen getunt kann man das
nicht nennen ich habe die kassette gewechselt dass noch ein bisschen
größere übersetzung hat für berge hoch oder kleiner kann man das immer nicht
merken das gewicht ich habe also ich hatte letztens mal 80,5 das habe ich auch
auf paar tage später dann auf twitter gepostet die leute fanden das wieder
ganz toll so diese wagen post die gehen immer richtig gut wobei das wirklich ein
sehr glücklicher tag war ja tag davor nicht viel gegessen
sport gemacht davor wahrscheinlich sogar ein bisschen zu wenig gedruckt als
80,5 ist wirklich äußerst optimal aber möglich normal ist irgendwie irgendwie
würde ich eher sagen 82 oder so es ist glaube ich eher das normale also wenn ich
mich jetzt da an einem normalen tag wenn ich normal viel gefordert habe vorher
aber morgens auf die waage stelle oder so dann müsste das so in dem tritt etwas
runtergefallen also so in dem dreh
würde ich sagen 82 worum aber ist trotzdem gar nicht übel ich meine ich
habe angefangen mit 108,5 sind 16 ne quatsch nicht nicht nicht 60 war bei 92
waren das 16 kilo jetzt sind das 26 kilo so viel ist ja den unterschied
merkt man echt 26 kilo mehr oder weniger als echten riesen unterschied überlegt
euch mal 26 kilo das sind 6
6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6 6
26 Milchpackungen.
So ungefähr.
Also 26 Kilo, das ist echt, boah, das ist
viel mehr, als ich das jetzt im Kopf hatte, ne?
Das ist richtig, richtig
nice. Darf man sich nicht beschweren.
Also ich hab schon,
ich hab schon, ich hab's schon am Anfang gemerkt.
Ich mein, da hatte ich ja die Katz noch und
allein schon, wenn ich
mit der mal irgendwie
auf der Erde rumgekrabbelt bin oder so,
war das schon ein riesen
Unterschied. Egal,
also war das schon ein riesen Unterschied jetzt.
Also 108 versus
98 war schon ein riesen Unterschied,
ja. Die 10 Kilo, das hat man richtig
gemerkt. Und wo man's
natürlich auch merkt, ist,
aber das ist eher so subtil, weil
das so langsam ging.
Wenn man
Sport macht, merkt man das natürlich auch.
Also wenn du einfach
jedes Kilo, was du weniger mit dir rumtragen
musst, umso besser.
Gerade berghoch beim Fahrradfahren ist jedes Kilo
spürbar.
Letztens
bin ich, bin ich
eine Runde, bin ich eine Runde bei uns
gefahren. Und das war hier,
kannst du grad zeigen,
Google Maps,
ähm, war hier.
So ein kleines
Kaff.
Und da geht,
da geht hier,
hier geht die Straße lang, genau.
Hier,
hier bin ich hochgefahren, Bergstraße.
Und da geht's,
da geht's relativ, relativ,
wenn man das
sein soll. Ah, das ist der
Wegweiser. Ja, ich bin dann
hochgefahren quasi hier durchs Ort. Ich bin
quasi von hier unten irgendwie
nicht ganz sicher, ich bin nicht ganz sicher, wie ich
hier bin ich wahrscheinlich rüber,
Bergstraße noch. Da geht's relativ steil hoch,
da sind's zwischenzeitlich mal in die 20%
Steigung. Hoch, hoch, hoch. Und hier
geht's dann quasi durch den Wald weiter
den Berg hoch bis, bis da, bis, bis hier
so. Dann ist man oben und dann geht's.
Ja, zumindest, als ich hochgefahren bin,
guck ich so neben mich und
da kommt so mit, keine Ahnung, so einem
halben kmh schneller
kommt ein Rentner an mir vorbeigefahren.
Also hier ist, also hier ungefähr
so diese, die letzten paar Dinger
so ab, ab dem, wo man hier abbiegt, ne, so
ab, wo man da so um die Ecke fährt.
Das, das sind, das sind durchaus mal
20%, wo es hier, es geht wirklich steil hoch.
Und da kam so
mit einem, mit einem halben kmh schneller
als ich oder so, kam so ein Rentner an der
linken Seite an mir vorbeigefahren.
Und, äh, guck ich
so, ich, ich hab ja, ich hab ja mittlerweile
so Pedale,
wo man guck, nein, ich will jetzt nicht, ich google mal.
Ich hab ja mittlerweile Pedale,
wo man gucken kann, wie viel Watt
man so in die Pedale tritt.
Und ich guck halt, dass ich's nicht übertreibe, so, dass
ich den kompletten Berg halt auch durchschaffe, ja.
Und
guck dann, guck halt auf mein, guck
halt auf mein Garmin-Computer und seh so, ich hab so
irgendwas so um 200 Watt.
Und da denk ich mir so, okay, mag's
nicht übertreiben, passt schon, ne.
So ab 170, es wird für mich
ab, auf Dauer alles anstrengend, da lachen
sich natürlich die, die, äh,
begübteren Fahrradfahrer kaputt, aber
immer noch besser als, äh, die Oma,
die sonntags noch zum Bäcker fährt.
Das weiße 200, da pack ich den Berg hoch,
danach muss ich mich ein bisschen ausruhen, weil das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Danach geht's ja dann hier wieder steil
bergab. Zumindest
komm da halt so mit einem halben
KMH, so ein Rentner an mir an der linken Seite
vorbeigefahren. Sieht so komplett
entspannt aus, easy mode.
Guck ich mir das halt an, E-Bike.
Ja, wink ich ihm so,
kurz so, wie man halt so
ein bisschen die Hand gehoben, ja, so, da, moin.
Und da hat er
irgendwie, irgendwie auch was
erzählt hier. Er hat's ja auch
ein bisschen einfacher, ja.
Hat er auch. Für den
sah das easy aus. Mit nem E-Bike
20%ige Steigung fahren ist anscheinend
easy as fuck.
Ich bin da, ich bin da hoch, hoch
gerampelt
mit ein bisschen über 200 Watt.
Und das ist nicht schnell, ja.
Ich mein, ich wieg immer noch über 80 Kilo
und
hab, gibt's bestimmt irgendwo
irgendwelche Rechner, wie schnell man
mit 20 Kilo und 200 Watt
den Berg hochfährt. Nicht schnell,
kann ich euch sagen. Ich fahr
teilweise, also die richtig steilen Anstiege,
gerade wenn die lang sind,
also ein paar hundert Meter lang, oder
nicht ganz so steil und noch ein bisschen länger,
ja, gerade
an den Rampen hatte ich oftmals das Problem,
dass ich da so langsam gefahren
bin mit dem Fahrrad, dass
mein Garmin-Computer meint, ich würde stehen.
Aber da, ich glaub, der, also der
Garmin-Computer ist eingestellt, alles, was
unterhalb von 8 kmh ist,
ist, ähm,
geht da auf Pause.
Und 8 kmh
bei so ganz steilen Dingern ist halt
auch nicht grad wenig, ja.
Muss man erst mal hochschaffen.
Das hab ich aber mittlerweile ausgeschaltet.
Hast du dieses Jahr wieder lange Urlaub?
Ja.
Hab ich.
Wenn ich jetzt noch
einen finde, mit dem
ich zweimal,
Sachen tauschen kann,
Ende November,
dann bin ich sogar eine Woche früher
weg. Dann bin ich quasi,
eh so ab, bin ich quasi ab
23. November
hab ich dann Urlaub. Bis
nächstes Jahr. Jeden Tag
streamen. Mal gucken.
Aber öfters auf jeden Fall.
Weiß ich, ob jeden Tag, aber öfters.
So gab der, den hatte ich schon, ne.
Geht nicht wegen Berufsschule, ja, ist halt gern.
Dafür musst du wenigstens nicht, wenn du
Berufsschule hast,
in den Betrieb gehen.
Also ich weiß, Berufsschultage sind ja so, dass man nicht mehr in den Betrieb gehen muss.
Das juckt.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was war es, ab, ab, ab fünf Stunden oder so, Berufsschule muss man nicht mehr in Betrieb?
Gab's auch so ne Regelung.
Ich wusste nach der Berufsschule nie in Betrieb.
Egal, wie lange gekotzt die war.
Was auch der Grund war, warum ich eigentlich ganz gerne in die Berufsschule bin.
Berufsschule an sich war mega Schrott, aber
dass man danach nicht ins Betrieb musste, war gut.
Ja dann, das so.
Übrigens, wo wir gerade beim Thema Berufsschule sind, lasst mich doch gerade mal kurz gucken,
ob es da neue schöne Bilder von meiner ehemaligen Berufsschule gibt.
Die Bewertungen werden auch immer besser.
Die Webseite ist bestimmt immer noch so die Oldschool-Webseite von, ne, ja, doch, doch, doch.
Übrigens, was witzig ist, ne, es gibt auf dieser gesamten, ja doch, hier gibt es Fotos, aber das, das sieht halt, es sieht halt schon,
guck mal, es sieht aus wie ein Knast, diese Berufsschule. Guckt euch das an, Alter.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum die da Fotos überhaupt davon, davon haben.
Es sieht so, guck mal, sogar Wachtürme haben die.
Ja, guckt euch, das ist so hässlich, diese Berufsschule, Alter.
Und das ist noch, das ist die Cafeteria, das ist noch die schönere Variante. Ich wette mit euch, ja, und ich wollte, ich wette mit euch, die Klassenräume und die Gänge
zeigen sie nicht, nein, natürlich nicht. Die sehen ja auch zu räudig aus, die zeigen sie natürlich nicht. So zeigen die Cafeteria,
das, wo im Prinzip eigentlich kein, das ist übrigens richtig eklig, was es hier, was es hier gibt, ja.
Also, mit Stimme.
Ich will hier nicht hin, ja.
Aber glücklicherweise, Berichte nennt sich das jetzt so.
Kann man das nicht sortieren, Neueste?
Zwei Fotos, okay.
Äh, was der Noah Toys macht, ich will wissen, was der für Fotos hat hier.
Ach, nicht von der Schule, so insgesamt hat er zwei Fotos.
Okay, ein Stern, ein Stern, ein Stern.
Wie kann das möglich sein, im Jahr 2014, ist,
ein Stern.
Die Schule geht ja,
die, die, die, die, die geht ja richtig ab.
Okay, boah, das ist ja mal eine richtig ausführliche,
ausführliche Rezession hier zur Berufsschule.
Neben dem Mangel an Parkplätzen, ja, das haben wir jetzt schon oft genug gelesen,
den unzureichenden gepflegten, das war, das war bei mir auch schon so, ja.
Das einzige, wo du in dieser Schule aufs Klo gehen konntest,
waren die, waren die Pissrinne, äh.
Da gibt's, da, ihr kennt das ja, bei, auf Herrentoiletten gibt's ja manchmal keine
Klos, sondern einfach nur Rinnen.
Das war das einzige, was es, was es da gibt, wo man,
wo man so halbwegs rein konnte.
Und der Rest muss man da wirklich auf großem Abstand halten.
Für Altenauswürde gibt es an dieser Schule weitere Auswürde.
Es fehlt eine, eine ordentliche Kantine, das stimmt wohl auch.
Die Kantine ist wirklich eklig.
Die Lehrkräfte hervorheben, die meinen, ah, okay.
Den hatte ich auch, den Str, Str und Wenn hatte ich auch.
Die waren aber ganz neu damals.
Die gibt es anscheinend immer noch.
Haben durch ihren, das war, das ist bei mir schon eine ganze Weile her, ja.
Haben durch ihren, äh, äh.
Guckt euch ja, ja, so sehen die Kloster aus, Alter.
Alter, die Kloster, ne.
Ja.
1997, da siehst du ja, wie alt das Geschmier da ist und nie jemand weggemacht hat.
Einfach mal irgendein SS-Logo hängen wollen, all die Leute, das kannst du klicken, man.
Guckt, guckt euch diesen Scheiß an.
So, so sehen, so sehen alle Toiletten aus, ne.
Wobei das gar nicht Toiletten sind, das ist irgendeine Tür, ne.
Aber das ist garantiert.
Aber hier unten sieht man es ja.
Das ist Kachel, das ist auf dem Klo, oh.
Eine Berufsschule, ja.
Katastrophaler Zustand.
Endlich hat die Fachinformatikerschule WLAN.
Boah, hui.
Das sind die ja vor vier Monaten.
Da sind die ja richtig Bleeding Edge unterwegs, oder was sagt ihr?
Jetzt schon WLAN im Jahr 2024.
Das ist aber wirklich krasse Neuigkeit.
Gute PCs, ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Ich könnte wetten, die hatten immer noch, die haben immer noch die gleichen PCs wie bei mir.
Vor 20 Jahren, ein bisschen über 20, ein bisschen, ein bisschen unter 20, 18 Jahre.
Ja, die haben bestimmt immer noch die gleichen Schrott-PCs mit Windows XP.
Mit Windows XP.
Und wir mussten damals, wir haben damals auch virtuelle, also VMs gehabt.
Die waren allerdings nicht mit, vor allem bei Workstation, Virtual Box.
Die waren mit, wie hieß dieses Ding?
Microsoft Virtual PC oder sowas.
Ja.
Virtual PC von 2003 durch Microsoft übernommen.
Genau das.
Das mussten wir damals verwenden.
Das ging aber in der Tat ganz gut.
Ansonsten sind die bewährt.
Schlechte Lehrer, schlechte Parkmöglichkeiten, alles dreckig.
Nicht viel Deutsch sprechende Objekte an der Schule.
Na gut, das stimmt wohl.
Das liegt aber auch mit daran, dass das nicht nur eine Berufsschule ist.
Das sind ja alle, ja.
Also alles, was es so gibt, was noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise Richtung Schule geht,
ist ja da.
Da ist schon teilweise, sagen wir mal, auch recht bildungsferne
Leute unterwegs.
Schule sieht aus wie ein moderner Knast.
Ja, das stimmt. Das dachte ich von dem Ding auch immer.
Hab nichts damit zu tun, Bruder kam weinend zwar auch nach Hause.
Echter Drogen-Umschlagplatz.
Gang-Rivalitäten stehen an der Tagesordnung.
Das habe ich so nicht mitbekommen in der Berufsschule, dass es dort, dass dort viel
gedealt wird oder Gang-Rivalität herrschen würde.
Das, dass das halte ich für etwas übertrieben.
Aber um es noch besser zu machen,
gab es da nicht, gibt es da nicht auch Fotos von?
Oh ja, guckt euch mal an.
Ist es nicht, ist es nicht wunderschön architekturtechnisch, die Schule?
Toll, oder?
Das sieht so einladend aus, so, so offen, freundlich.
Und, und hell.
Das ist ein Klassenzimmer.
By the way, das Bild ist von, okay, 2018.
Wir reden hier von 2018.
Das ist jetzt vielleicht nicht super
aktuell, aber damals war immer noch Tafel und Overhead-Projektor angesagt, ja?
Ich könnte wetten, heute ist es immer noch Tafel und Overhead-Projektor 2024.
Ja, guckt, guckt euch hier diese Mauern an.
Das war schon ein bisschen wie im Knast, diese Berufsschule.
Und sonst noch ein bisschen was.
Nice, Frankfurt bei Nacht, sehr schön.
Okay, Sporthalle, der Schulhof, Dreck draußen, Dreck drinnen.
Random, das Foto kenne ich schon, Random Matratze draußen.
Die Klassen 2020, die Klassenräume sehen halt echt auch teilweise aus wie im Knast.
Sehe ich da vorne einen Overhead-Projektor?
Also ich sehe hier ein paar Bildschirme, aber ich glaube, ich sehe, ich glaube, ich
sehe da vorne auch hier einen Overhead-Projektor.
Was ich toll finde, dass immer noch, ist natürlich doof, dass jetzt dieses Ding da drüben, dass immer
noch Eastpack-Rucksäcke angesagt sind.
Das war bei mir schon im Trend.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass das immer noch angesagt.
Ich dachte, heute ist es irgendwas anderes.
Eastpack-Rucksäcke, Rucksäcke.
Und die Leute, die damals
furchtbar edgy und cool sein wollten bei mir in der Schule zu meiner Schulzeit.
Wisst ihr, was die gemacht haben?
Wir haben sowas gemacht.
Die haben sich ein Edding geschnappt, haben das Eastpack-Logo genommen.
Wie macht man das? Wie macht man das hier?
Wie macht man in Paint den den Stift größer?
Geht das?
Wie macht man in Paint?
Ich bin zu blöd für ich bin so dumm, hier Paint zu benutzen.
Brush. Okay, gut.
Und jetzt die Size.
Keine Ahnung, ich bin zu dumm für.
Zumindest was die, was sie gemacht haben, ist folgendes.
Die haben das eh weggemalt.
Okay, so.
Das ist jetzt die die Original
2000er Experience, die ihr hier kriegt.
Die haben das eh weggemalt von Eastpack
und haben die Seiten von dem T weggemalt von Eastpack.
Und dann stand am Ende noch Asipak da.
Und die sind dann damit rumgelaufen, haben sich richtig geil gefühlt.
Manche Leute waren auch richtig modern, haben dann auch hier so ein i draus gemacht.
Das hatten die Leute dann auf ihrem Rucksack stehen und haben sich richtig abgefeiert dafür.
Das hat man zu meiner
Schulzeit gemacht, weil man sich besonders cool und
edgy gefühlt hat, hat man das Eastpack Asipak gemacht.
Oh, das sieht die Schule nicht einladend aus.
Geil, oder?
Oh, da hat man richtig Bock, wenn man das so sieht.
Oh ja, und diese, diese, das sieht so einladend aus, diese Schule, Mann.
Guck mal, das von 2022 sieht immer noch so aus.
Bei mir haben sie Spikes an den Rucksack gemacht.
Wie darf man sich das vorstellen?
Sieht das einladend aus.
Wie? Oh, guckt euch das mal an.
Das, das sieht, das sieht wirklich aus so, so offen und freundlich, als will man da hin.
Ja, das ist der Blick von der Gutloystraße aus.
Das ist der Eingang hier vorne.
Da bin ich jeden Morgen rein.
Dann also jeden Morgen, wenn Berufsschule war.
Das sieht von außen halt echt aus, wenn du das so siehst.
Das sieht wirklich, also diese Beschreibung sieht aus wie ein Knast.
Das ist nicht übertrieben.
Das sieht wirklich aus wie ein Knast.
Mich würde fast nicht wundern, wenn das mal als Knast geplant war, dieses Gebäude.
Alles ist so.
Das sieht so hässlich aus.
Okay, das war's an Fotos.
Da ist da ist angeblich eine Kantine.
Das halte ich jetzt aber.
Das ist ein. Das ist dieser Imbiss.
Das ist dieser Imbiss, der sich die Kantine nennt.
Ja, den kenne ich.
Den gab es damals auch schon.
Ich bin mir aber nicht sicher, ob es den überhaupt noch gibt.
Was hat er so? Was hat er so für Bewertung?
Der hat gute. Okay.
Das ist wahrscheinlich in Ermangelung.
Alternativen.
Mangel an Alternativen.
Aber da war ich auch ein paar Mal.
Das war aber ganz okay.
Gibt's auch schon ewig.
Na ja, gut, genug.
Genug Frankfurt Brudi.
Sowas hat man sich damals an die.
Sowas hat man sich damals an den.
Rucksack.
Das, das, das gab es bei mir nicht.
Bei mir haben sie.
Bei mir war das höchste der Gefühl, dass man das Eastpac Asipac macht.
Zeigt mir eine schöne Schule.
Das Problem ist ich.
Man kennt ja immer.
Seine Schulen.
Ja, ups.
Und ansonsten guckt man da nicht großartig.
Keine Ahnung.
Es gibt sicherlich schöne Schulen.
Was ich gehört habe in Frankfurt ist wohl richtig nice, was Schulen angeht.
Ich habe letztens ein Video geguckt.
Vom Held der Steine.
Der hat sich drüber aufgeregt, dass es jetzt eine neue Schule in Frankfurt gibt
und dass die Schule schon Kinder annimmt für das nächste Schuljahr, obwohl die Schule
gar nicht fertig gebaut ist und die Schule wahrscheinlich auch die nächsten zehn Jahre nicht fertig wird.
Und das jetzt genau das sind jetzt irgendwelche Container.
War das bei dir auch so oder warum warst du im Container?
Das ist quasi jetzt eine Schule in Frankfurt, die besteht nur aus Containern.
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich weiß nicht, welche das welche das jetzt genau war.
So genau habe ich dem Video nicht auf aufgepasst.
Suchen wir doch mal.
Suchen wir doch mal hier Frankfurt Container Schule.
Ja, Stadtgymnasium genau spezialisierte Bildung im Container.
Da das sieht ein bisschen aus.
Das sieht ein bisschen aus wie in China
dieses Profi Professionskrankenhaus, was sie während Corona gebaut haben.
Oder halt so eine so eine Bauarbeiter Unterkunft.
Das ist Real Life Docker.
Also die haben halt das Problem, die wollen eine Schule bauen
und die brauchen auch eine Schule.
Aber die schaffen es halt wieder nicht.
Guckt euch das an.
Aber die schaffen es halt mal wieder nicht.
Was zu bauen, weil das in Deutschland immer 30 Jahre braucht.
Bis da Gymnasium Süd.
Genau Schule wird ab Sommer 2025 vorübergehend aufgeteilt.
Eltern vor der neuen Stunde bis 2027.
Das ist halt. Und wisst ihr, wisst ihr, was besonders bitter ist?
Dass es in Frankfurt passiert, weil Frankfurt hat Geld.
Frankfurt müsste eigentlich theoretisch
zumindest eines der reichsten Städte der Welt sein oder zumindest eines der
reichsten Städte in Deutschland, weil Moment ernsthaft,
weil Frankfurt hat so viele Einnahmen und nicht so viele Einwohner.
Frankfurt hat halt sehr viel.
Also Frankfurt ist halt eine Stadt, die hat keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es nicht genau.
Ich sage jetzt einfach
Frankfurter tagsüber irgendwie keine Ahnung, drei Millionen Einwohner und irgendwie
abends 800.000 oder so was.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die Werte stimmen.
Das ist jetzt einfach ausgedacht.
Aber es ist halt extrem, weil Frankfurt hat halt viele Business Standorte.
Und
im Verhältnis dazu nicht so viele Einwohner.
Also Frankfurt hat tagsüber extrem viel mehr Leute als eigentlich da wohnen.
Aber die ganzen Unternehmen, die dort sind, die bezahlen halt und die
müssen halt auch ordentlich bezahlen in Frankfurt.
Das heißt, Frankfurt müsste eigentlich super.
Viel Geld haben.
Aber sie kriegen es nicht auf die Reihe.
Sie kriegen es irgendwie nicht gebacken.
Es gibt auch für jeden Schrott NPM Packages, oder?
Das ist aber das ist aber doch eindeutig irgendein Meme Package.
Why check if something is odd simply when you can do it with AI?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Lass uns mal den Source Code angucken.
Da passiert tatsächlich ein bisschen was.
Wo liest er den Chat-GPT-API-Key ein?
Gar nicht. Doch braucht man hier.
Process Event Open-API-Key.
Nice.
Ich glaube, das hat die Welt definitiv gebraucht.
Dieses Package.
Also das ist essential.
Hätte es das nicht gegeben,
hätten wir, glaube ich, JavaScript nicht weiterverwenden können.
Aber wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Leute, ich glaube, ich werde heute off-
stream ein bisschen am Fiat-Champ weiterprogrammieren, mir mal überlegen,
wie man das aufbauen könnte mit mehreren Accounts.
Irgendwie Bock drauf.
Vielleicht, wenn mir was Gutes einfällt,
vielleicht machen wir on-stream auch ein bisschen was.
Es gibt doch IsEvenAI.
Es gibt wahrscheinlich mittlerweile nichts, was du dir ausdenken kannst.
Nichts in JavaScript.
Könnt ihr euch noch daran erinnern?
Vor vor einem Jahr oder so, wo irgendeiner einen NPM-Package gemacht hat,
was eine Dependency hatte auf alle anderen NPM-Packages.
Erinnert sich da noch einer dran, was einfach NPM gnadenlos kaputt gemacht hat?
Sieht man, ob das schon von anderen verwendet wird?
Das kannst du, glaube ich.
Ähm.
Depends. Depends.
AI is even.
Also, ja, AI is even depended daran.
Aber, aber nichts, aber niemand depended on AI is even.
Ne, Moment, ich habe das falsch rum interpretiert.
Leute, ich habe das falsch rum interpretiert.
Ich habe das falsch rum interpretiert.
Es ist falsch rum, was ich gesagt habe.
Chat, und ihr habt es nicht gemerkt.
AI is even depended hier auf AI.
Also ja, die haben eine Dependency, aber die wiederum hat niemand, der darauf depended.
Also insofern ist das, sind das reine Meme-Projects.
Aber so sehe ich, der hat immerhin schon mal 130 GitHub-Sterne.
Mehr als der Fiat Champ.
Der hat letztens 100 Sterne gepackt.
Oh ne, ich wurde, ich wurde entsternet letztens.
Sadge.
Was vielleicht daran liegen mag, dass ich die Software nicht mehr aktualisiert habe seit zwei Jahren.
Aber alles, Leute, alles Anwendungsfehler.
Jeep Remote Start.
Hat der, hat der irgendeine ID, die man schicken muss?
Everything else works great.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Nach zwei Jahren immer noch.
Also eins muss man tatsächlich im Fiat lassen.
Ihre API scheint stable zu sein.
Polifisch, danke für den Sub.
Ich habe vor, ja, ziemlich genau zwei Jahren.
Das letzte Mal war es committed und der Kram funzt immer noch.
Also die Fiat API ist relativ, relativ stable.
Was aber gut ist, wenn ich daran ein bisschen rumbasteln will, kann ich immer
noch den alten Shit verwenden und weiß, dass es funktioniert.
Alternativ kann ich mir das auch abgucken.
Es gibt auch
für IOProker gibt es einen Fiat Adapter.
Weiß nicht, ob der noch weiterentwickelt wird.
Anscheinend. Der entwickelt wohl noch.
Besslo, der, der entwickelt das Ganze
wohl noch weiter.
Das heißt, da könnte ich nachgucken, wie er das mit dem Login macht.
Wo ist es denn?
Admin?
Ob sich da was geändert hat?
Wo ist denn der eigentliche Source Code?
Hier, main.js wahrscheinlich.
Ja, ach, guck mal, der.
Okay, der macht das, der macht das wie ich.
Der hat auch diese API Keys einfach im Klartext drinstehen.
So, so wünsche ich das auch mal.
Die sind ja nicht geheim.
Die sind ja global.
Die sind ja von Fiat.
Okay, der hat im Prinzip, der macht es sehr ähnlich zu dem ich das auch mache.
Dieb. Ja, hier genau.
Login, URL. Okay, da hat er halt der Support hat auch Jeep.
Das hat bei mir nicht richtig funktioniert.
My Uconnect Fiat. Und wo macht er den Login?
Hier macht er den Login. Ja, okay.
V2 Accounts.
This Login. Okay, wo kommt das her?
Wo ist Login? This Login.
Okay, was? Was macht er hier?
Web SDK, das sieht, das sieht ähnlich aus zu dem, was ich habe.
Und ich habe mir da auch ein paar Sachen von abgeguckt.
Damals.
Ja, das ist, das ist im Prinzip, das hat er seitdem auch nicht mehr aktualisiert.
Das ist im Prinzip das Gleiche, was ich, was ich auch mache.
Wie macht er denn dieses komische Amazon Ding?
Irgendwo.
Irgendwo müsste da eigentlich auch noch ein Amazon Ding kommen.
Das ist ja auch Dependency Hell, oder? Request then, request then, request then.
Ah, hier Amazon Identity.
Okay, das macht er auch so auf manuelle.
Ja, also der Fiat Login Prozess ist wirklich Hardcore Magic.
Kann man nicht anders sagen.
Du musst dich, du musst dreimal Tokens holen, fünfmal einloggen.
Ach ja, ich bin übelst müde heute, Mann.
Dabei habe ich laut meiner Garmin und Garmin Uhr irgendwie einen Sleep Score von
89. Top, das ist nur okay.
Aber ich habe auf jeden Fall gepennt.
Ja, dann lass uns doch mal ShitHub Trends angucken.
Was geht heute?
Heute hat ja jeder, hat ja jeder frei.
Ich stream so jetzt erst mal bis heute Mittag.
Dann wird ein bisschen Proggerstells gemacht.
Aber vorher muss ich noch meine, muss ich um eineinhalb Stunden, werden es heute nicht,
so 1.20 rum, muss ich mal eine Runde rennen.
Sonst bin ich nicht ausgeglichen.
So 1, 1.20 rum.
Ich werde so ungefähr, ich werde wahrscheinlich
die, ich weiß nicht, wo ich die Runde abkürze.
Also ich habe so eine Runde, die ich gern laufe.
Wenn ja, es ist Sonntag, ist nicht Montag.
Ich habe eine Runde, die ich gern laufe für so längere Runden.
Und die kann man auf mehrere Arten laufen, je nachdem, wo man abbiegt.
Ja, die kann man entweder so ungefähr
11,5 Kilometer rennen oder 14 Kilometer, 14,5 Kilometer.
Immer die Frage.
Biegt man quasi
die gleich ab oder biegt man das nächste ab?
Zeig mal deine Runde auf Maps Kegweight.
Und bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich glaube, ich glaube, ich lasse es heute bei 11,5 Kilometer,
weil ich bin gestern schon 45 Minuten gerannt.
Relativ schnell.
Ansonsten, wenn das langsam gewesen wäre, das ist nicht so relativ schnell.
Und
wenn ich heute noch mal 11 Kilometer renne,
so semischnell, nicht übertreiben, ja, dann reicht das eigentlich echt.
Jetzt? Nee, nee, nee.
Irgendwann um 13 Uhr oder so, 14 Uhr nach dem Mittagessen irgendwann.
Was meinst du mit rennen? Ja.
Der Übergang von Joggen zu Rennen ist fließend.
Es gibt Umfragen.
Kein Witz, es gibt wirklich Umfragen, die gemacht wurden.
Ab wann Leute den Übergang sehen?
Nein, nein, nein, das hast du falsch verstanden.
Das hast du falsch verstanden.
Ich war gestern 45 Minuten rennen.
Das waren keine 11 Kilometer.
Für 11 Kilometer brauche ich ein bisschen über eine Stunde.
Also die Leute sind sich nicht ganz einig,
wann der Übergang von Joggen zu Rennen ist.
Der ist irgendwo zwischen sechs Minuten pro Kilometer und 4,30.
4 Minuten 30 pro Kilometer.
Irgendwo dazwischen ist der Übergang von Joggen zu Rennen für viele Leute.
Das ist so sehr subjektiv.
Also ich würde sagen, der Übergang.
Also bei mir ist der Übergang von Joggen zu Rennen.
Ja, so irgendwie tatsächlich irgendwo so bei 5,50 so rum.
Also 5,30 kommt mir schon nach Rennen vor.
6,30 kommt mir noch nach Joggen vor.
Wie würdest du es denn dann nennen, wenn Marathonleute
und Rennläufer 2 Minuten 50 pro Kilometer über 40 Kilometer rennen?
Die Joggen sicherlich nicht mehr.
Die rennen schneller als die meisten Leute sogar kurze Strecken nur rennen können.
Müsst ihr euch das mal vorstellen?
Die rennen 2 Minuten 50 pro Kilometer über 40 Kilometer.
Die Joggen schnell, aber rennen sicherlich noch schneller.
Okay, die vielleicht, die vielleicht.
Ich nicht, ich nicht.
Ich renne nicht schneller.
Also ich würde auch sagen, Sprinten ist halt so schnell
wie man persönlich kann, ja.
Also ich finde schon, dass es das ist irgendwie so bei so bei 5,45 rum ist für
mich persönlich vom Gefühl her der Übergang von Joggen zu rennen.
Vom Geschwindigkeitsgefühl her.
Das ändert sich übrigens auch.
Also am Anfang hätte ich das niedriger angesetzt.
Aber wenn ich jetzt ich meine, ich habe mal als ich angefangen habe, ja,
als ich angefangen habe, da bin ich 8,15,8,30.
Gelaufen ohne, also so, so, so, dass ich nicht kaputt war.
Das ist im Prinzip heute.
Ich kann heute keine 8 Minuten pro Kilometer oder 8,30 pro Kilometer.
Das kann ich gar nicht.
Das da komme ich, da komme ich mir vor, als laufe ich rückwärts.
Also ich kann im Prinzip nichts langsamer
als 7 Minuten pro Kilometer mehr laufen, ohne dass ich das Gefühl habe,
überhaupt mich zu bewegen.
Das ist das ganz weird.
Am Anfang war 7 Minuten pro Kilometer.
Boah, war das schnell, Alter.
Also mein Lieblingstempo ist so um 6,20 rum.
6,6, 6,20 pro Kilometer ist so mein mein Lieblingstempo.
Das kommt ja halbwegs zügig vor, ist aber nicht groß anstrengend, so dass man
denkt, boah, jetzt, wann haben wir es denn endlich geschafft?
So 6, so 6,20 rum.
Das ist eigentlich so meine.
Wie nennt man das so?
Meine, meine Lieblings, meine Lieblings Geschwindigkeit.
Mario Dankeschön für den Sub.
Exzellente Subscriptions hier.
Nice.
Der Wohlfühl Pace, genau.
Sicherlich nicht der beste Pace, wenn man, wenn man sagt, ey, man möchte
einfach so lang wie möglich, dann ist es sicherlich noch ein Ticken langsamer.
Wenn ich jetzt, also wenn ich jetzt sagen
würde, ey Max, du, du, du musst jetzt 40 Kilometer rennen.
Das wird wahrscheinlich meine Schienbeine gar nicht mitmachen.
Dann würde ich das garantiert nicht mit 6,20 rennen, sondern würde wahrscheinlich
sagen, lass mal ein bisschen langsamer machen.
Aber.
Heute, das werde ich so ungefähr 6,20, denke ich mal, rennen.
So das ist das 6,20 einfach sehr angenehm.
Ja, so was trendet denn
diese Woche auf GitHub?
Animation Engine.
Warum?
Chatge, ich bin verwirrt.
Warum ist das und das hier beides am Trenden?
Ist es ein Fork?
Okay.
Gibt es, gibt es aus Gründen zweimal?
OCR.
Das ist tatsächlich interessant.
Alles so viel Python-Stells am Start.
OCR-Stells.
Ja, ach, der hat ein Video gemacht, deswegen.
Coolie. All-in-One-Project-Management-Plattform.
Eine Alternative zu Jira Slack.
Ja, das ist aber, das ist aber ein hochgestecktes Ziel, oder?
Einfach mal alles an Tools ablösen.
Okay, gucken wir uns das mal an.
Okay, das sieht schon mal, da hat sich einer von Apple inspirieren lassen, so ein
bisschen, oder? Von diesem Bild.
Das sieht schon sehr Apple-like aus.
Rocker in Sveld, siehste?
Backend TypeScript, Sveld, beste Kombi hier.
Naja, gut, Backend TypeScript bin ich jetzt nicht so der Fan von.
Aber gerade wenn man Sveld-Kit verwendet, ist es wahrscheinlich das Beste.
Try it free.
Moment, ich glaub, das ist der Darkreader, der das ein bisschen kaputt macht.
Okay, ganz ehrlich, das ist mir schon ein bisschen zu viel Spielerei.
Hier kannst du ja kaum was erkennen.
Vor lauter.
Alter, das ist, das ist vielleicht minimal Effekt-Overload.
Aber cool gemacht, oder?
Guck mal, das leuchtet, das leuchtet sogar
die umliegenden, die umliegenden Elemente an.
Es ist aber vielleicht ein bisschen übertrieben mit den Effekten hier.
Also da hat er echt, da wollte er echt seine CSS-Skills demonstrieren, oder?
Ist auch so eine Seite mit so komischem Scroll überschrieben und sowas.
Try it for free.
Okay, 10-Minute-Mail, ich will mir das jetzt mal angucken.
In die Zwischenablage kopieren.
Ich hoffe, ich hoffe, dass das funzt, ja.
Ich hoffe, wir kriegen jetzt eine Bestätigungs-E-Mail.
Also der hat CSS durchgespielt, ja.
Ich glaube, der schickt nicht an irgendwelche temporären...
Näh, ich glaube, der, ich glaube, der lässt eigentlich...
Lässt eigentlich rein, Gachibas, hier
mit so einem Fake-Fake-E-Mail-Account.
Ist halt ein bisschen sad.
Zum Ausprobieren wäre das halt nice gewesen.
Aber es ist, es ist, na, ob das responsive ist, wissen wir ja gar nicht.
Ist es responsive?
Ja.
Leute, die Seite ist ultra responsive.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Hyper responsive Seite ist das hier.
Ist die Pricing-Seite auch responsive?
Boah, okay.
Also der Typ übertreibt es echt mit seinem CSS-Kram.
Ist das überhaupt möglich, mit CSS so was zu machen hier?
Chat, das geht bestimmt.
Aber meint ihr, das ist CSS-Animation oder der hat da irgendwelche Sachen im
Hintergrund, irgendwelche GIFs oder so? Ich glaube nicht.
Ich glaube, das ist CSS.
Das integriert sich zu gut in die Seite sonst.
Und es scaled halt auch richtig, richtig gut, ja.
Das ist, das ist CSS.
Oder S...
Svg plus CSS, ja.
Aber der wollte schon, der wollte schon ein bisschen flexen mit seinen CSS-Skills, oder?
Was denkt ihr?
So ein bisschen.
So ein bisschen, der bisschen CSS-Flex ist da schon dabei.
Ich muss sagen, für meinen Geschmack ist die Seite vielleicht ein bisschen,
bisschen overloaded an Effekten und Dingern, ja.
Aber schon ziemlich heftig CSS-geflext.
Come on, Epic Legendary!
Hat sogar die
Hat sogar die Hearthstone-Farben.
Bei Common ist in Hearthstone, glaube ich, grau, ne?
Aber, aber hier Epic und Legendary passt.
400 Euro im Monat, easy.
AI, ja, das...
Ach ne, wir haben es hier.
Hulu Information Code, nice.
Jetzt habe ich es aber schon zugemacht.
Moment.
Huli. Sign in.
Okay.
Workspace Name.
Keckel.
First Name.
Lulwe.
Kekwe.
Skip kann man skippen, okay.
Start using...
Boah, muss ich kein...
Muss ich kein Passwort oder irgendwas vergeben?
Du hast jetzt wieder 100 Sterne für den Fiat Champ, nice.
Dann wird's, dann wird's echt mal Zeit, da weiter dran zu bauen, hä?
Ich muss mir aber irgendeine gescheite Architektur überlegen.
Wie man damit mehrere Accounts verwalten kann.
Weil das ist echt so ein fundamentaler Flaw in diesem Ding.
Man kann im Endeffekt nur einen User angeben.
Und wenn es wirklich Leute gibt, die vielleicht
einen Fiat und einen Jeep haben, vergiss es, funzt net, kannst du eine Sache.
Selbst Leute, wenn Leute zwei Fiat Autos, zwei Autos von Fiat haben, zwei
unterschiedliche Accounts, geht's auch net.
Und so wie ich das gesehen habe, gibt es durchaus Leute, gerade bei den Amis,
gerade habe ich ja auch in den Issues und so gesehen, dass es durchaus Amis gibt, die
beispielsweise hier
einen Fiat haben und noch irgendwie so einen Dodge Truck oder so oder einen Jeep.
Scheint, scheint da nicht so unverbreitet zu sein.
Was kann ich machen, wenn nächstes Jahr das Support für Windows 11, für Windows 10
aufhört, ja auch für Windows 11 updaten? Was willst du sonst machen?
Du kannst ja auch Extended Support kaufen als Privatperson, weiß gar nicht, ob das geht.
By the way, Max,
hast du nicht die Readme Emojified?
Die ist genauso, wie es sein muss.
Die Seite Readme, das ist wichtig.
Okay, also das ist
Huli.
Was?
Kann man das mit irgendwas synken?
Das wird mir ja vielleicht auch noch in den Settings.
Kann man das mit irgendeinem Kaldaff oder sonst wie was synken?
Oder gibt es gibt es davon?
Gibt es davon Mobile Apps?
Das wäre ja auch schon mal.
Gibt es gibt es Huli für iOS?
Nee.
Ah ja, gut, es ist halt ein ein weiterer von drei Milliarden.
Planner Tools.
Ganz ehrlich, soll ich euch mal was sagen?
Wenn ich wirklich so eine so eine umfassende
Planning und Kontakte und Chat und alles in einem Geschichte bräuchte,
dann würde ich wahrscheinlich echt einfach Outlook benutzen.
Auch wenn ich, ich hasse Outlook.
Splixer, danke für das.
Ich kriege Anfälle bei Outlook.
Aber wenn ich wirklich so was will, was einfach all in one hat.
Nextcloud ist Schrott.
Ich mag Nextcloud nicht.
Dann würde ich wahrscheinlich einfach Outlook nehmen.
Backlog erledigt.
Aber nicht schöne, nicht schön CSS Checkboxen auf jeden Fall.
Und die Checkboxen, die sind nicht, die sind nicht gut CSS.
Testet er das vielleicht nicht in Firefox?
Sorry, nur es keine Ahnung.
Ich würde keine Betriebssysteme nehmen, die einfach nur versprechen.
Also das ist irgendeine Linux Distribution.
Ich würde keine Betriebssysteme nehmen, die versprechen, dass sie wie Windows sind,
weil letztendlich sie sind nicht wie Windows.
Es ist in Linux.
Man muss sich da drauf einlassen, dass es ein anderes Betriebssystem ist.
So kann man sein Account wieder löschen?
Account Settings.
Okay, Account ist disabled.
Ach, jetzt muss ich Workplaces wieder createn.
Kann ich nicht meinen Account löschen?
Also wenn du wirklich gar keinen Bock hast,
kannst du persönlich das Update auf Windows 11 empfehlen?
Das ist ja die gleiche Frage, ob ich Windows empfehlen kann.
Naja.
Ich kann Windows dann empfehlen, wenn man nicht dran vorbeikommt.
Das weiß ich nicht.
Hast du Sachen, die du nur unter Windows machen kannst?
Oder spielst du Spiele mit Anti-Cheat, dann kommst du nicht an Windows vorbei.
Ansonsten
ist es, wenn du nichts hast.
Ganz ehrlich, wenn du nichts hast, was Windows voraussetzt.
Ja, Spiele.
Also wichtig sind Spiele mit Anti-Cheat, da hast du unter Linux keine Chance.
Viele anderen Games funktionieren mittlerweile ganz gut.
Dann bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig.
Also ich könnte das Update empfehlen in diesem Fall, wenn du halt Windows brauchst,
weil Windows 10 ist bald out of support nächstes Jahr und es wird realistisch
betrachtet und Update auf Windows 11 das lösen können.
So, wie kann man nur sein Account löschen?
Kann man irgendwie Settings?
Okay, das ist so. Account Settings.
Man kann nur den Workspace liefen.
Hooli. So machen wir mal.
Hooli Delete Account.
Geht wahrscheinlich.
Geht wahrscheinlich einfach nicht.
Subscript.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nicht Hulu.
Hooli gibt's nicht, kann man nicht.
Wird nicht, wird nicht gelöscht.
Das ist aber auch nicht schlimm, weil wie lockt man sich denn aus?
Weil ich habe mich eh nur in einer Fake-E-Mail-Adresse registriert, die jetzt
wieder weg ist gleich. Zack, bam.
Deine temporäre E-Mail-Adresse wurde gelöscht.
F. Weg ist es.
Und bei Hooli.
Jetzt frage ich mich mal ernsthaft.
Wenn ich mich jetzt hier einlogge mit.
Dem da. Ja, dann kriegt man eine neue.
Okay, so ist das.
Man vergibt gar kein Passwort mehr anscheinend.
Gut, das funzt ja nicht mehr, weil die E-Mail-Adresse ist weg.
Mal gucken, ob die alte noch geht.
Mal gucken, ob das alte noch funzt.
Ja gut, dann ist der E-Mail-Account, dann ist das jetzt einfach weg.
Gut, nie wieder irgendjemand kann jemals wieder drauf zugreifen.
So, ich wollte aber immer noch gucken, was auf GitHub eigentlich
trendet, warum immer da der Fiat Champ jetzt am Start ist.
Trending Repositories.
Papermark.
Du musst kein Windows 11 kaufen.
Ist das Upgrade nicht sogar kostenlos auf Windows 11 von Windows 10?
Das Update ist doch kostenlos, oder?
Das kostet doch nix.
Ja.
Du kannst upgraden, das kostet nix.
Brauchst du, musst nix kaufen.
Du kannst, ich glaube, du kannst sogar.
Windows 11 heute noch aktivieren mit einer Windows 7 Lizenz.
Es ist unabhängig davon, ob ich das empfehle oder nicht.
Ich kann mittlerweile sicherlich nicht mehr ruhigen Gewissens Windows empfehlen,
gerade seit dieser ganzen Recall-Scheiße.
Aber es ist realistisch betrachtet die einzige Option, die du hast,
wenn du Windows-Only-Sachen hast, wie beispielsweise Spiele mit Anti-Cheat.
Dir bleibt schlicht und ergreifend nichts anderes übrig.
Windows 11 Upgrade ist sicher das kleinere Übel, wie ein Betriebssystem
ohne Updates zu verwenden.
Du hast versucht, den Audio-Codec zu ändern.
Wie soll man denn den Audio-Codec ändern?
Audio-Codec ist was, mit dem die,
das File, was du abspielen willst, encoded ist.
Oder was meinst du mit Audio-Codec ändern?
Weil von einer schon encodeten Datei kann man den Audio-Codec nicht einfach ändern.
Dazu muss man die Datei decoden und neu encoden.
So mit FFmpeg zum Beispiel, da hat Windows nix mit zu tun.
Oder meinst du das hier,
wo ich vergessen habe, wo ist Sound-Settings?
Moment, Moment Leute, wir müssen ja
Control Panel, Sound, da müssen wir ja hin, weil Windows da suckt.
Oder meinst du das hier, supportete Formate und so Zeug hier?
Meinst du das hier?
Das ist auch sowas, das kann man über das
Control Panel machen, aber nicht über das andere.
APTX 2.
Was zum Teufel ist?
APTX 2, das habe ich noch nie gehört.
Chat, wisst ihr, was das ist?
Ist das irgendeine 3D-Klang-Simulation oder Low-Latency-Synchronized-Audio-Technology?
Bluetooth-Codec, habe ich noch nie gehört.
Ist mir komplett neu, keine Ahnung.
Ja, Windows-Settings sind immer so ein Pains-Champ, weiß man nicht, wo was ist.
Was trenne denn sonst noch?
Building a modern, old sales...
Eine Salesforce-Alternative, na dann.
Ist nicht das Ding bei Salesforce so, dass sie so beliebt sind?
Einfach, weil die so viele fertige Sachen
auf der Box haben, wo man sich nichts drum kümmern muss, auch nichts selbst hosten muss und sowas.
Number one Open Source CRM.
Wenn die das sagen.
Hanko.
Ach ja, da hat doch gestern irgendjemand gefragt nach, wie er das machen würde.
Habe ich ihm gesagt, er soll Key Cloud verwenden.
Ist das eine Alternative dazu?
Das ist das und wie darf man sich das...
Kann das in VICE?
Naja, so was haben wir sonst noch am Trenden?
Knowledge Management Software.
Okay, das ist irgendwie Elektron-based, oder?
Wollen wir mal wetten, Leute?
Elektron-based. Gibt es zumindest schon mal für Linux.
Das ist schon mal gut. Das ist doch 100 pro.
So wie das aussieht, Leute, ist das 100
pro tausendprozentig Elektron-based.
Weiß halt nicht, warum ich das nehmen sollte versus was anderes.
Warum sollte ich das nehmen versus irgendwie?
Emoji. Ganz wichtig.
Habe ich nicht gerade Emoji irgendwo gelesen?
Ah ne, Editor. Okay.
Sad.
Ohne Emoji-Support.
Okay, es gibt wohl für iOS eine App.
iOS.
Das ist was, was ich mir tatsächlich mal rauskopiere.
Vielleicht ist das gar nicht so übel.
Kann das To-Do's oder so? Irgendwas mit Notification?
Kann das Notifications?
Nee, oder?
Ich cheater.
Für Chinesen, Digga.
Was ist mit Obsidian?
Obsidian kann keine Mobile Notifications.
Das ist das, was mich ein bisschen davon abhält, das mal auszuprobieren.
Ich finde halt Notifications, wenn die auf
allen Plattformen unterstützt werden, sehr praktisch.
Da kannst du irgendwie reinschreiben so ey, Max, denk dran.
Bis Freitagabend hier.
Machst du den, machst du dann rein.
Ihr add oder eben so, add 20.10.20 Uhr und dann kriegst du dann auf allen
Plattformen, wo du das gesynkt hast, eine Nachricht.
Kann Obsidian leider nicht.
Mobile Notifications, bisschen doof.
So.
Und ansonsten trendet noch Deno.
Dino, muss man ja sagen.
Dino.
Altralytics, Jolo 11.
Das ist so ein Image Detection.
Wusste nicht, dass die mittlerweile bei 11 schon sind.
Custom Firmen für die Nintendo Switch.
Oh, lass das mal nicht Nintendo sehen.
Wobei das ist ja nicht verboten, sowas zu
programmieren, ist es aber auch streng genommen nicht verboten.
Emulations Software zu programmieren und trotzdem sind die alle weg.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es mitgekriegt habt.
Yuzu ist ja schon ein bisschen länger weg und jetzt ist Rio Jinx oder so.
Jigs oder wie das hieß, ist auch weg.
Jason for Modern C++.
Wollen wir mal, wollen wir mal lachen, wie hässlich Jason in C++ ist.
Also das ist State of the Art Modern C++ Jason.
Brauch erst schon mal 30 Seiten readme, dass man das checkt als Normalsterblicher.
Ja gut, parsen ist.
Ich will, ich will gucken, ob das dynamisch
Objekte serialisieren und deserialisieren kann.
Was ist das für eine krasse
Syntax?
What?
Okay, ich lerne immer wieder neue Sachen
an Hässlichkeiten von C++.
Was ist das schon wieder?
Rapid Chasen
von Tencent gibt es auch.
Gibt es auch auf, ah hier.
Also was, was ich halt immer interessant finde, ist können die
die Chasen Libraries können die Objekte
serialisieren und deserialisieren.
Also Jason parsen.
Und dass ich dann damit irgendwie
Array Syntax oder so drauf zugreifen kann, das ist, das ist das Mindeste.
Aber wichtig wäre, dass die Dinger
komplette Objekte serialisieren und deserialisieren können.
Das ist ja das, was die meisten Jason
Parser in den meisten modernen Sprachen eben können mittlerweile.
Das ist halt gerade das Praktische.
Schauen wir mal, ob das hier das kann.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall schon mal hässlich aus.
N Lohmann klingt auf jeden Fall deutsch.
Ja, das stimmt.
Chasen es First Class Data Type.
Ja, okay.
Das ist alles schön und gut.
Aber kann man Objekte serialisieren und deserialisieren?
Serialisieren from two strings.
Okay, sieht hässlich aus, aber passt schon.
So und jetzt.
Objekte würden mich halt interessieren, ob das geht.
Streams.
Range.
Custom.
Wie hässlich möchtest du sein?
Ja, ich bin C++.
Ich möchte so hässlich wie maximal möglich sein.
Und das geht noch. Das ist auch vollkommen okay.
Das kann man noch lesen.
Aber es ist einfach immer so.
Es sieht schon immer so zum Kotzen aus.
Ich weiß was. Was ist das hier?
Using Reference gleich Kunst Char und Sachs Interface.
Gibt es nicht wie
wie sehr realisieren und deserialisieren ich irgendwelche Objekte?
Ja, das frisst Standard Container.
Verstehe ich auch.
Okay, leuchtet ein.
Jason.
Leute Merch.
Ich will einfach nur wissen, wie ich Objekte sehr realisieren, deserialisieren.
Danach gucke ich mir das von Tencent an.
Okay, erst mal wissen wir das hier.
Arbitrary Type Conversions.
Okay.
Also hier haben wir eine Person.
Nee, das ist immer noch okay.
Nee, hier haben wir ein Struct Person.
So, das ist quasi.
Convert to Jason.
Copy each value into Jason.
Ja, Moment, das ist ja für.
Das, das, das ist das Mindeste, was gehen muss.
Das ist eine Syntax, die mir, die ich absolut nicht verstehe.
Was passiert hier?
Chat, kann mir irgendjemand schlüssig
erklären, was ich hier überhaupt vor mir habe?
Was sehe ich denn hier?
Was bin ich hier sehend?
Ich verstehe es nicht.
Punkt Template.
Get was?
Was sehe ich hier überhaupt?
Convert from Jason.
Das, das leuchtet mir gar nicht ein, was ich da gerade sehe.
Okay, aber ich will einfach nur wissen, wie ich, wie ich Objekte sehr realisieren.
Und diese. Also machen wir mal ein Beispiel.
Ja,
in in.net würde das irgendwie ungefähr so aussehen.
Jason Converter.
Ich weiß es jetzt aus dem Kopf nicht.
Ja, Jason Convert.
Ich kann halt mal schreiben Converter.
Und dann würde ich so was sagen wie keine Ahnung.
Ähm, serialize.
Und da.
Ja, New Blub so so und da würde dann oder oder Blub.
Da würde dann quasi einen Jason raushauen von meinem Objektor.
Und dann könnte ich auch, dann könnte ich auch quasi sagen, die serialize.
Ich will das gerne als Blub und dann hier halt den Jason String.
So, so würde das Internet ungefähr aussehen.
Also relativ easy.
Und da kriege ich hier einen Blub Objekt raus, was erstellt wird aus dem Jason
String, sofern der Jason String eben die, ähm,
die Felder enthält, die das Objekt hat.
Das ist also Internet ist das wirklich sehr, sehr simpel.
Ich hätte eigentlich gehofft, dass das irgendwie mit C++ auch funzt.
To make this work with one of your types, you only need to provide two functions.
From Jason to Jason.
Ja, aber ich muss das alles von Hand machen.
Da kriegst du Anfälle von.
Simplify your life with Makros.
Das ist meistens G-Bait.
Meistens machen es Makros nicht simpler.
N-Loman-Define-Types.
Type non intrusive.
N-Loman-Define-Type intrusive.
Ah ja, that's all easy.
Obviously examples.
Okay, aha.
Ah ja, also ich define hier meine Class und dann packe ich irgendwie N-Loman-Define-Type
intrusive rein für die Properties und dann generiert er mir to and from Jason dafür.
Ich muss euch ehrlich sagen, das wirkt reichlich.
Es liegt. Ich muss auch mal sagen,
das ist sicherlich nicht hier.
Da kann er wahrscheinlich nichts dafür.
Das sind die Unzulänglichkeiten von C++.
Das wirkt mir aber doch sehr behelfsmäßig, dass man sowas braucht.
Dieses Makro wird unter der Haube wahrscheinlich
genau das hier anlegen für jeden.
Für jeden Namen, den ich hier übergebe.
Fuck man, ist das kompliziert.
Und irgendjemand hat im Chat jetzt noch gepostet, gepostet, gepostet.
Ist schwer, dass wir das links kopieren.
Das ist in C++ gar nicht so unüblich,
weil in C++ musst du halt immer gucken, dass es keine doppelte Benahmung gibt,
weil C++ und C, gerade C, du hast da halt nicht
irgendwie in sich geschlossene Module und Makros gerade sind global.
Deswegen gibt es immer wieder Probleme, weil viele Libraries Makros definieren, so
was wie Min oder Max und das hast du dann doppelt und dreifach und kommst du in die Quere.
Das ist halt alles Old School Legacy Shit, man.
Allein schon das Rumhantieren mit Headern.
Es gibt keine gescheiten Package Manager und keinen gescheiten Modulsupport.
Es gibt zwar mittlerweile Module, aber dass sich das jemals durchsetzt.
So, also angeblich finden wir laut Chat, finden wir hier ein besseres Beispiel.
Also mich würde vor allem auch das Deserialisieren interessieren.
Also.
Klaas Persson, Public Persson,
okay, bla bla bla, das ist okay, Standard.
Das ist quasi eine Klasse mit zwei.
Ehrlich gesagt habe ich keine Ahnung, was ich hier überhaupt jetzt schon an der Stelle sehe.
Was ist RHS?
Persson.
Ach, das ist eine Person von einer anderen Persson initialisieren.
Name Underscore.
Ach so, private müssen wir gucken.
Ach hier, hier ist es okay.
Sag mal, die Chinesen müssen auch
alles anders machen, ja? Warum sind private Variablen bei den Chinesen H
Underscore und nicht Underscore H?
So.
Protected, Template, Writer, Void, Serialize.
Ja, du musst das ja auch ja selbst machen.
Du musst, hier passiert ja genau das gleiche.
Hier musst du das ja auch selbst machen.
Den Serialization Code.
Das ist halt, das ist halt Schrott.
Warum kann es nicht die Library für dich machen?
Wie gesagt, in einer ordentlichen Programmiersprache.
Es ist egal, ob das Go ist.
In Go kannst du das so machen.
Ob das Java, C-Sharp ist, Python, wie auch immer.
Aber bei Python weiß ich es aus dem Kopf gar nicht.
Da geht das bestimmt, Python geht das garantiert sogar noch besser, weil das
alles so dynamisch ist, das ist ja geradezu geradezu gemacht für solche Geschichten.
Also in, ja nehmen wir mal das hier zum Beispiel.
Programme.
So, also in .NET kann ich folgendes machen, um euch das mal kurz zu demonstraten.
Okay, so in .NET kann ich beispielsweise
sowas machen. Ich habe hier eine Klasse, Cute Chatter.
So, der hat, keine Ahnung, ein
Username und und dann hat er noch ein Bool,
ist Prime Sub.
Was zahlst du für die Chatbrains Lizenz?
Ich hab, ich hab
das All Desktop Package schon mehrere Jahre.
Also ich bin in diesem, müssen wir mal gucken.
Es kostet im ersten, zweiten und dritten Jahr unterschiedlich.
Nicht All Products.
Das ist auch Organisation for Individual Use.
Early Billing.
Ich bezahle 173 Euro im Jahr.
Ach ne, mit Mehrwertsteuer 205 Euro im Jahr.
Aber als Streamer bezahlt man noch nichts.
Das kenn ich bei Chatbrains nicht.
Also ich bezahle 205 Euro im Jahr.
Und man bekommt halt alles, was die haben.
Ich finde das, ich finde das echt okay, weil.
Moment.
Chapa C++.
Was ist das?
Ach, wie Visual Studio im Prinzip ist in
Sila das wahrscheinlich schon drinnen.
Also von diesen Dingern benutze ich Rider sehr oft.
Goland semioft, Sea Lion ab und zu.
Und den Rest doch Rush Rover.
Rush Rover haben wir auch schon benutzt, aber selten.
Pycharm auch selten.
Ja.
Also ich benutze quasi 6 Produkte, aber davon nur, sagen wir mal, 3 regelmäßig.
Das kann sein, dass ich da, ich frage die doch nicht, ob ich das umsonst kriege.
Ich bezahle 205 Euro im Jahr und gut ist, dafür kriegt man ja auch was.
So, was ich eigentlich zeigen wollte.
Also, in .NET ist das super, super easy.
Du sagst JSON Converter.
Äh, nicht, du sagst JSON Convert.
Leute, ich bin ein Kacknub.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das mit dem neuen Kram funktioniert.
Ähm, wir nehmen jetzt mal eine Library, wo ich weiß, wie es funzt, okay?
Ich bin da zu nubig für.
JSON Convert.
So, das meine ich.
So, JSON Convert.
Dann sagst du jetzt einfach Serialize Object.
Und, ähm, okay, du hast hier eine Variable.
Äh, Chatter gleich new.
So, und, ähm, das ist, wir machen hier keine Autocomplete.
So, UserName.
UserName ist, haben wir hier den ERF-Programmer.
Und, äh, ist PrimeSub, muss man leider sagen.
Er chattet zwar viel, ist er aber nicht.
Nehmen wir trotzdem mal als Beispiel.
So, zack.
Warum geht das nicht?
Ach so, weil es falsche Reihenfolge ist.
So.
So, und wenn ich jetzt sage, ich will das hier serialisieren als JSON, ist das alles, was ich machen muss.
Und jetzt gehen wir mal nach Repos.
Zip.
Äh, .NET.
.NET Run.
Und ihr werdet sehen, bam, UserName, zack, es geht als JSON-String raus.
Also sprich, dieses Objekt kann 1 zu 1 als JSON-String serialisiert werden.
Er nimmt einfach alle Public-Felder oder Properties und macht daraus, äh, einen JSON-String.
Man kann mit ein bisschen Config das Ganze so beeinflussen.
Hero, fette Mutti.
Danke für den PrimeSub.
Ähm, man kann das ein bisschen konfigurieren, dass der beispielsweise, ähm, Bool-Values als 0 oder 1,
schreibt und Strings beispielsweise dann, äh, groß oder, äh, kann man alles konfigurieren,
aber im Prinzip ist das alles, was man machen muss.
Man hat ne, man hat ne Klassendefinition, das könnte übrigens auch ein Struct sein oder ein Record oder so.
Hier, Record ist auch, äh, okay, ja, wird, wird genauso funktionieren.
Was sag ich, egal, was man da hat.
Und dann hat man ne Variable davon und kann die einfach serialisieren.
So, und jetzt kommt das Beste.
Umgedreht, wenn ich jetzt einen JSON-String hab, den da zum Beispiel.
Nehmen wir mal den hier mal als Beispiel.
So easy geht das in C++ nicht.
Ja, das ist mir auch gerade aufgefallen.
Ist aber sehr sad, dass das nicht geht.
So, jetzt machen wir mal das Umgedrehte.
Ich, äh, habe keine Variable davon, sondern ich möchte eine, ein JSON-String zurückumwandeln in ein cute Chatter-Objekt.
Aber in C++ willst du auch nicht in JSON.
Warum nicht?
Äh, gerade, gerade wenn du irgendwelche, äh, Web-Requests und Sachen hast, dann kommst du ja an JSON nicht wirklich vorbei.
Oder auch für Config-Files ist JSON sicherlich nicht das Schlechteste.
Also ich hab beispielsweise schon, äh, von meinem Microcontroller JSON-Daten ausgeliefert an ein, äh, Web-Frontend.
Und das ist, musst du halt in JSON machen, da kommst du nicht drumherum.
Man will generell nicht mit C++ arbeiten, das, das stimmt wohl, ja.
Mu, Mooncure, Cure, dankeschön.
Bock, Subscriptions, danke Leute für die ganzen Subs.
So, jetzt machen wir das Umgedrehte.
Ich hab gar kein Objekt, nur einen JSON-String.
Und ich will jetzt daraus einen Chat.
Und ich will einen Chat erzeugen.
Dann sage ich einfach JSON-Convert, Deserialize-Objekt.
Und zwar, ich möchte, dass du mir aus diesem JSON-String, aus diesem JSON-String hier, ein Cute-Chatter-Objekt machst.
Und jetzt gehen wir das, wir machen mal einen Record, dass es schöner geprintet werden kann.
Und jetzt führ ich das raus und zack, siehe da, ich bekomme ein Objekt raus mit den Daten aus dem JSON-String.
Ist das nicht nice?
Ohne irgendwelche...
Extra-Spezialsachen.
Einfach nur Deserialize, sagen als was, String rein, schieben und es geht.
Nice, oder?
So hätte ich jetzt eigentlich gehofft, dass es in C++ auch geht.
Aber das ist anscheinend nicht der Fall.
Rider ist beste.
Er ist richtig pock.
Ach, JSON-Serializer ist es, das Eingebaute.
Genau, nicht JSON-Convert, JSON-Convert war es früher.
Ja.
Man sollte aktuell eher JSON-Serializer benutzen, weil das die Build-In-Variante ist.
Nee, PHP-Store benutze ich nicht.
Willst du dich nicht als Student einschreiben, soziale Arbeit?
Hä?
Wie jetzt?
Wie meinst du das?
Soziale Arbeit als...
Was zum...
Den Zusammenhang checke ich jetzt nicht.
Benutze nur VMware Workstation, ja.
Also hier, Windows und VMware Workstation.
In Go ist es ähnlich easy.
Ja, da hast du JSON-Marshall oder sowas.
In Rust bin ich mir nicht sicher.
Ach, damit ich eine kostenlose Lizenz bekomme.
Haha.
Verheiligt.
Rust weiß ich nicht.
Serde.
Serde ist top.
Das habe ich schon mal verwendet.
Das ist easy.
Da geht das ähnlich gut.
Aber es ist Rust.
Das checkt keiner auf den ersten Blick.
Aber guck hier.
Serde Form String Data.
Sogar in Rust geht das auch dynamisch.
Guck.
Serde checkt das.
Du musst halt das hier drüber schreiben.
Das implementiert dann ein paar Magic-Sachen für dich.
Aber das ist ja okay.
Das ist tatsächlich gar nicht so unähnlich zu der C++.
Variante.
Nur deutlich eleganter.
Aber hier geht das dann auch.
Aber lohnt sich Chatbrains so sehr im Vergleich zu VS Code und VS Visual Studio?
Ähm.
Es kommt ein bisschen auf dich an, wie viel du die Produkte benutzt.
Ja.
Also, wenn es jetzt mal um .NET-Entwicklung geht.
.NET-Entwicklung kannst du in Visual Studio Code vergessen.
Das ist Schrott.
.NET-Entwicklung musst du, wenn schon, in Visual Studio machen.
Und das gibt es nur für Windows.
Ich glaube, Mac wurde mit der C++-Variante verwendet.
Das wurde mittlerweile eingestellt.
Das heißt, wenn du unter Linux unterwegs bist, hast du gar keine andere Möglichkeit als Rider.
Okay, es gab früher noch Mono-Develop.
Ich weiß nicht, ob man sich das noch geben möchte.
Also, es bleibt dir eigentlich gar nichts anderes übrig als Rider.
Und Rider ist eine super Idee.
Generell sind die ganzen Chatbrains-Dinger ziemlich gut.
Also, ich verwende von diesen Chatbrains Sachen.
Ich verwende Rider, PyCharm, Goland und Rust Rover.
Und ab und zu, hier habe ich tatsächlich gar nicht erzählt, ab und zu noch C-Line.
Ja.
Die fünf Sachen verwende ich.
Rider mit Abstand am meisten und Goland.
Der Rest unregelmäßig, aber verwende ich.
Also, das kann man ja auch machen, wenn man das so hat.
Atom ist dead good.
Da gibt es aber einen Fork von.
So.
Und für Frontend-Sachen benutze ich Visual Studio Code.
Also, Frontend-Sachen mache ich nicht in WebStorm, sondern das mache ich in VS Code.
Ja.
Und oftmals sieht es bei mir dann so aus.
Ich habe beispielsweise hier.
Ja.
Ja, hier habe ich meinen.
Also, oftmals habe ich das, je nachdem.
Ich habe, ich habe meistens auf drei das, wo ich gerade mehr daran arbeite.
Ja, also, bei mir sieht das meistens so aus.
Ich habe mein Frontend-Stells hier auf dem dritten Desktop auf.
Hier habe ich dann im Endeffekt die Vorschau von der, vom Frontend.
Und hier habe ich dann irgendwo mein Backend laufen,
mit meistens dann hier noch ein Terminal, wo ich dann .NET Run,
meine Backend-Anwendung starten kann.
Also, das ist meistens so die Kombination, wie ich das aufgeteilt habe.
Oh.
Hier Terminal immer auf zwei, auf eins, immer den Browser, auf zwei immer das Terminal,
auf drei immer die IDE, beziehungsweise den Editor, wo ich gerade hauptsächlich was dran mache.
Und auf vier, falls ich noch irgendwie was Zweites brauche, beispielsweise auf drei Frontend
und auf vier dann irgendwie das .NET Backend, habe ich das so.
Wenn ich am Backend hauptsächlich bastele, dann ist das auf drei und das Frontend auf vier.
Auf drei ist immer, weil kommt man easy, kommt man einfacher hin, ja, auf der Tastatur.
Auf drei ist immer das, wo ich gerade hauptsächlich dran arbeite.
Ja.
Manchmal habe ich auf acht, manchmal habe ich auf acht noch irgendwie einen extra Browser offen,
mit irgendwelchen Dingern zum, wo ich irgendwas nachgucken muss, abgucken muss, ja.
Was ist der Vorteil von JetBrains Zeugs versus Visual Studio Code?
Das kommt darauf an, was du meinst, also, oder was du machen willst.
Also, für Frontend-Sachen, habe ich ja gesagt, benutze ich selbst Visual Studio Code.
Dafür könnte ich auch beispielsweise Dings hier verwenden, WebStorm, WebStorm habe ich mir mal angeguckt.
Habe ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht so den großen Vorteil gesehen versus Visual Studio Code.
Da gefällt mir Visual Studio Code besser, gerade durch die ganzen vielen Plugins,
dass es beispielsweise auch das offizielle Svelte-Plugin und sowas dafür gibt.
Also, da hat es keine Vorteile, da benutze ich weiter Visual Studio Code.
Für andere Sachen wie zum Beispiel .NET-Entwicklung hat es riesen Vorteile,
weil die .NET-Tools in Visual Studio Code Schrott sind und sehr hakelig sind und nicht richtig funktionieren.
Das ist von Sprache zu Sprache unterschiedlich.
Wie gesagt, für Frontend-Sachen, würde ich sagen, hat es keinen Vorteil.
Ich weiß, es gibt welche, die schwören, auch WebStorm, aber mir gefällt Visual Studio Code für Frontend-Sachen besser.
Aber für Backend-Sachen und generell für so, für was anderes, für was anderes als, ja, ist echt so, ja.
Visual Studio Code .NET ist wirklich mega Paints-Champ, ja.
Ja, und für andere Sprachen wie Go, .NET oder Rust oder sowas, da finde ich es angenehmer,
dass in den JetBrains-Produkten so was ist.
Also, es ist nicht so, dass man in den JetBrains-Produkten so machen kann,
weil es eine, ja, rundere, rund, runder läuft, out of the box als Visual Studio Code.
Gerade C++ ist in, in VS Code sehr langsam und sehr, sehr laggy
und die Autocompletion geht ab und zu mal kaputt.
Aber für umsonst ist es noch in Ordnung, ja.
Ja, ich bezahle 205 Euro im Jahr für meine JetBrains-Desktop-All-Products-Package.
Ist die Programmsuche Bestandteil von I3?
Äh, du meinst, meinst du das hier?
Duck, duck, duck, duck.
Meinst du das hier?
Dass ich hier sagen kann, Firefox, nee, das ist, das ist nicht direkt Bestandteil,
das ist aber relativ beliebt, das ist RoFi, nennt sich das, RoFi.
RoFi ist was.
Guck mal, der hat sogar mittlerweile eine Weile für Wayland geforgt, das ist RoFi.
Das kann auch übrigens noch mehr.
Du kannst hier nicht nur Programme suchen, du kannst auch,
also das ist egal, du kannst, äh, offene Fenster suchen,
Woffi wird aber nicht mehr entdeckt, du kannst Emojis sogar suchen,
äh, du kannst ein Clipboard durchsuchen,
ja, und du kannst Skripts ausführen, das brauchen wir jetzt aber nicht.
AI.sh, das ist Gbait, das macht nix.
Also das hab ich, das hab ich so eingerichtet, dass man das,
ich benutze eigentlich hauptsächlich, also ich benutze zwei Sachen.
Ich benutze die App-Suche und ich benutze die Clipboard-Suche.
Also das ist quasi meine Zwischenablage.
Und wenn ich, wenn ich hier was, hier kann ich auch drinnen suchen, hier, so, keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung, ich wollte schon, ich, ich hab schon immer noch Windows 11, Englisch, X,
Anasco 64, so, und wenn ich das hier auswähle, dann kopiert das mir auch ins Clipboard
und ich kann's jetzt damit einfügen.
Aber wenn ich sag, hier, ich suche nach Qt Chat, irgendwas, das da,
dann ist das in der Zwischenablage.
Das ist sehr praktisch.
Ja, Woffi gibt's auch, aber das wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt
und wird, glaub ich, auch nicht mehr empfohlen zu benutzen.
Oder doch? Ne, das ist das gar nicht, das Richtige.
Das ist das Richtige. Ne.
Oder ja. Kein Schimmer.
Man findet noch nicht mal das auf GitHub.
Kann das sein, dass es das nicht auf GitHub gibt?
Ist das auf GitLab oder so?
Ah, hier, das ist das Offizielle.
Wird nicht mehr weiterentwickelt, also kannst du knicken.
Oder, ach, kein Schimmer.
Du blickst dann immer durch, ey, bei dem ganzen...
Könnt ihr nicht einfach auf GitHub, wie jeder normale Mensch, ihr Zeug hosten?
Wayland ist immer so ein bisschen Hit und Miss.
Das Problem bei Wayland ist,
dass es nicht quasi so was ist wie X, was unten drunter ist,
sondern eigentlich nur eine Spezifikation, die jeder selbst implementieren muss.
Und das ist halt mal gut, mal schlecht gemacht.
Also, ich hab mit Wayland auch sehr viele Probleme gehabt.
Das ist übrigens der Grund, warum ich noch unter I3 und X unterwegs bin.
Und nicht wie die coolen Leute Wayland Hyperland oder so was.
Sieht hier aus. Okay.
Moment, was, was zum...
Da sieht ja gar niemand ein Beispiel bei.
Sieht aus wie hiermit, okay.
Polydynamic Data Parse JSON.
Ne, das ist nicht das, was ich, was ich meinte.
Ja, das können, das können die ganzen anderen Sachen auch.
S-String, okay.
Ne, das ist, das ist nicht das, was ich haben will.
Das ist genau das, was ich nicht meine.
Das sollte das Mindeste von einem JSON-Parser sein,
dass ich mit Array-Syntax auf die, auf die, auf die, auf die...
Auf den Inhalt von dem JSON-Data zugreifen kann.
Was ich meine, ist so was hier.
Du kannst das wirklich zu, ob zu Types serialisieren,
also Instanzen von Types serialisieren,
oder eben JSON zu Instanzen von Types deserialisieren.
Das ist ja gerade das, und das habe ich da nicht gesehen.
Ja, ich weiß. Aber ich meine, scheiß drauf.
Es funzt.
Und du wirst gefunden.
Ist das nicht gut?
Ist das nicht auch wichtig?
Zumal Git verteilt ist.
Selbst wenn Microsoft morgen GitHub abschaltet,
dann ist das Zeug immer noch da.
Und ja, ich kann die Bedenken teilweise schon verstehen.
Gibt ja Leute, die sagen, sobald der Code auf GitHub ist,
wird da automatisch in OpenAI verwurstet und so was.
Ach ja, aber es ist doch eh Open Source.
Also, also die könnten auch ohne Probleme einfach hingehen.
Das, das Crawlen von, von GitLab oder so machen sie wahrscheinlich auch.
Als würden die sich für irgendwelche Lizenzbedingungen interessieren,
die man da reinpackt.
Ist Hyperland besser als Sway?
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Läuft ja beides nicht richtig in der VM.
Also, ich habe Hyperland auf einem Mini-PC ausprobiert.
Das war eigentlich ganz nice.
Hört sich danach an, dass man viel ausprobieren muss,
um das Richtige zu finden.
Also, wenn man es besonders customizen will
und so was verwenden möchte wie ich,
ja, hier so ein i3-Tiling-Window-Manager,
und sich selbst die Sachen zusammenbauen,
ja, da muss man relativ viel selbst machen.
Aber du kannst doch einfach was verwenden, was fertig ist.
Du kannst ja auch einfach Linux Mint installieren
und dich freuen, dass alles out of the box funktioniert
und nichts machen musst.
Moin zusammen, das ist vielleicht etwas off-topic,
aber ich wollte doch mal nachfragen.
Ich bin dort Net-Entwickler.
Mit abgeschlossener Berufsausbegabe,
ca. 2 Jahre Berufserfahrung.
Alle meine Freunde von mir meinen, ich verdiene mit um die 1000,
viel zu wenig.
Wie ist da eure meine Wohne?
14 mal 14 oder mal 12?
Oder wir können es einfach mal mal 14 rechnen.
Ja, das ist viel zu wenig.
Das ist definitiv viel zu wenig.
NRW weiß ich nicht, aber es ist egal, wo, also, also,
ne, das erscheint mir für einen Entwicklerjob definitiv zu wenig.
Wahrscheinlich sogar, ja.
Ne, also das ist auf jeden Fall zu wenig.
Gerade, dass du jetzt auch nicht mehr der komplette Noob bist,
ne, das ist zu wenig.
Also, ich gehe auch mal ganz stark davon aus,
wenn du dich mal ein bisschen umguckst,
was es für Jobs bei dir in der Nähe gibt,
oder du hast ja heute auch die Möglichkeit,
dank Remote und Mobile Work bei vielen Unternehmen
so eine ordentliche Regelung zu finden,
wie ab und zu mal vor Ort und den Rest Homeoffice-mäßig.
Vielleicht kommt da auch ein bisschen was in Frage,
was ein bisschen weiter weg ist.
Wenn du dich mal umguckst, wirst du wahrscheinlich
sehr schnell was finden, was deutlich mehr bezahlt.
Weil, selbst mal 14 ist das echt nicht viel.
Also, 50k darf es durchaus sein.
Und selbst das ist noch nicht jetzt irgendwie super krass.
Ich wette mit dir auch, sobald du was anderes in Aussicht hast,
werden die feststellen, oh fuck, der rennt uns weg
und werden dir ein Gegenangebot machen.
Allerdings, das würde ich mir immer überlegen,
ob ich das annehme, je nachdem, wie die Firma drauf ist.
Weil, wenn du da Probleme hast, unabhängig mal vom Gehalt,
wenn es dir da eh schon nicht gefällt,
sind ja die Probleme nach einem Gegenangebot auch nicht weg.
Also, oftmals ist es gar nicht so eine gute Idee,
dann trotzdem da zu bleiben.
Aber, das muss man dann gucken.
Es schadet auf jeden Fall nicht, sich ein bisschen umzugucken.
Ich wette, du findest innerhalb von kurzer Zeit
was, was besser bezahlen würde, als das.
199,9%ig.
So.
Haben wir jetzt eigentlich alle Github-Trends durchgeguckt
oder habe ich wieder so ewig gelabert?
Ja, ich habe ewig gelabert.
LinkedIn-Profil, das stimmt tatsächlich.
So ein schlechter Ruf das Ganze auch hat.
Ein LinkedIn-Profil ist gar nicht mal so verkehrt,
weil, da kommen die Leute zu dir.
Das meiste davon, muss man aber sagen,
sind halt irgendwelche Recruiter-Azubis
oder Leute, die dort neu sind
und einfach random Leute auf LinkedIn anschreiben.
Aber zumindest,
hast du vielleicht mal ein bisschen so eine Einordnung,
was die denn bezahlen würden.
Ist gar nicht so verkehrt, mal zu wissen so,
okay, was würden da so bei anderen grob rumkommen.
Allerdings, wie viel da, ja,
Chat, ich bin ja kein großer LinkedIn-Benutzer,
das wisst ihr ja.
Ich kann schlecht beurteilen,
wie hoch die Ausbeute oder wie hoch der Anteil,
wie hoch der Anteil von Anfragen auf LinkedIn ist,
die man ernst nehmen kann,
im Verhältnis zum Kundrauschen auf LinkedIn.
Das kann ich schlecht einschätzen, ja.
Also ich würde fast sagen,
von zehn Anfragen auf LinkedIn ist vielleicht eine wert
oder eins in 20 oder so, ja.
Aber das ist nicht verkehrt.
Und man muss ja auch sagen,
viele Unternehmen wissen das mittlerweile.
Also die haben ja alle Probleme, Leute zu finden.
Und viele Unternehmen sagen,
hey, wir sind ja mittlerweile schon darauf umgeschwenkt,
quasi aktiv zu gucken nach Leuten,
die einen Job haben, aber dort nicht glücklich sind.
Also das ist ja mittlerweile eine gängige Recruitment-Strategie,
dass man versucht, Leute anzusprechen,
die eigentlich einen Job haben,
nicht aktiv auf der Suche sind,
aber mit ihrem aktuellen Job nicht so hundertprozentig
glücklich sind, sodass sie trotzdem empfänglich sind
für Angebote.
Weil die halt einfach wissen, ey, reine Stellenanzeige schalten.
Und die Leute kommen angerannt und rennen in die Bude ein.
Ist halt 2024 nicht mehr.
Gerade Leute, die planen, was sie machen.
Außerdem ist es cool zu sehen, dass die Leute einen haben wollen.
So, was trenne denn sonst noch alles so?
China-Chinesen-Zeug? Keine Ahnung, was das sein soll.
VPN-Stells vielleicht?
Alles klar, alles klar, alles klar jetzt.
Übersetzen.
Konnte man das nicht translaten lassen, gescheit hier?
Nee, oder das ging nur in Google, oder?
Oder konnte man in Firefox...
Gab es in Firefox eine ordentliche Translate?
Nee, das muss man, glaube ich, in Chrome aufmachen.
Da konnte man sagen, Translate to English.
Trading-Plattform.
Aha.
Ein Trading-System-Development-Framework.
Alles klar.
China-Chinesen-Trading-System-Development-Framework.
Ist GitHub aus China erreichbar?
Ich persönlich würde darauf tippen,
weil es saumäßig viele China-Projekte auf GitHub gibt.
Ganz ehrlich, ich glaube,
dass der chinesischsprachige Teil auf GitHub
der am schnellsten wachsende ist.
Und eins ist mir aufgefallen,
die Chinesen stehen enorm auf Java.
Viele Projekte aus China sind in Java programmiert.
Go und Python ist da auch beliebt,
dort nicht weniger,
aber man sieht total viel in Java.
Ich weiß nicht, was das heißt.
Man sieht total viel in Java.
Ich weiß nicht, warum.
Machine-Learning-Apps.
Autonomous... Autonomous... Autonome...
Ach, wie auch immer man das ausspricht.
Coding-Agent-Writing-Cable-of-Creating-Editing-Files-Executing-Command-Anmo...
Will ich das wirklich?
Will ich irgendwelche AI,
die lokal Commands executen kann?
Nee, eigentlich will ich das nicht, oder?
Nee.
Das will ich... Eigentlich will ich das nicht.
Guck hier, Java. China-Chinesen-Kram in Java.
Wobei, ich glaube,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Chinesisch ist.
Tooljet.
Low-Code-Plattform.
Die sprießen auch aus dem Boden,
wie sonst was.
Gucken, was im .NET-Umfeld trendet.
Diese Woche.
Die üblichen Geschichten.
Roblox-Launcher.
Was?
Implementation of the NTQQ...
Was ist das?
Lawful and Ethical Applications.
Was?
Implementation of the NTQQ...
Ich habe nicht den Hauch einer Ahnung,
was das sein soll.
Okay.
Die Weeps sind ausgebrochen wieder.
Es ist ja geil. Ich habe kein...
Was ist es denn?
Wie wäre es denn mal mit der Erklärung,
was es ist?
Was ist es denn?
Die tun so, als weiß die gesamte Welt,
was das NTQQ-Protokoll ist, Mann.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was das ist, Mann.
Geil. Das ist halt irgendwas...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was...
So ein Satz vielleicht.
Was es ist, wäre nicht verkehrt.
Bitworn ist wieder am Start.
WPF wird immer noch am Leben gehalten.
Was emuliert es denn alles?
Die alten 16-Bit-Dinger und sowas wahrscheinlich.
Ah, 64, ja.
Ach, da kann man TAS...
TASes mit erstellen.
Okay.
Maui.
Warte ich nur jeden Tag auf die Blog-Meldung,
dass Maui eingestellt wird?
Engine Impact Launcher.
ASP.NET.com.
Boah, das hat die Sterne auf jeden Fall verdient.
Okay. Alles klar.
So.
Es gibt ja auch nichts anderes.
Microsoft baut ja seit Jahren...
Scheiße mit UI-Frameworks.
Weiß nicht, was unpackaged
WinUI 3 Anwendungen
zu machen in der Zwischenzeit,
ob sie das mittlerweile hinbekommen haben.
Ja, Maui ist halt auch Schrott.
Niemand...
Niemand verwendet freiwillig Maui.
Ja, doch, wahrscheinlich schon, aber...
Ich würde es nicht freiwillig verwenden.
Also, wenn ich Cross-Plattform C-Sharp-GUI
bräuchte oder .NET-GUI, dann würde ich Avalonia nehmen,
aber selbst das triggert mich immer
mit ihrem komischen XML-UI-Zeug.
Also, was sie sich von
WPF abgeguckt haben.
Blazor ist bei mir auch unten durch. Ich sehe da
nicht den...
Blazor.
Ähm...
Ich sehe da für mich nicht den Vorteil.
Ganz ehrlich, ich finde die Kombination aus
Svelte 5 Frontend und .NET
Backend immer noch nice.
Vieles könnte man tatsächlich mit
SvelteKit und TypeScript serverseitig auch
direkt da machen.
Ohne .NET Backend.
Aber ich weiß nicht, ich finde die Kombination trotzdem gut.
Die Bitworn-Mobile-Clients
waren bis vor kurzem Maui, jetzt sind sie native.
Ja, wahrscheinlich, weil Maui Schrott ist, ne?
Übrigens, Maui unterstützt offiziell immer noch nicht Linux.
Auf der einen Seite
verständlich, ja, UI-Sachen
unter Linux, halt immer Paintschamp.
Aber für Maui nochmal extra Paintschamp,
weil die ja ihre UI-Elemente nicht selber
zeichnen, sondern auf
schon bestehende native
Libraries zurückgreifen. Und das halt unter
Linux so ein Ding. Auf welche willst du denn da zurückgreifen?
Auf GTK?
Oder willst du nur, dass es
unter KDE gut aussieht, oder was machst du, ja?
Deswegen sage ich, UI-Libraries
müssen ihre Elemente selbst malen, dass sie
cross-plattform-gescheit funktionieren.
Mit das Andere, du meinst Avalonia, oder?
Avalonia ist gut,
aber Avalonia triggert mich auch mit ihrem komischen
XML-Krempel.
Maui suckt.
Maui aufgibt.
Das wäre gar keine
so schlechte Idee.
Gibt es wirklich? Aber das wurde vor
drei Jahren zuletzt was.
Ich habe gerade nach Maui-Kit geguckt, da ist das Einzige, was ich
gefunden habe, ist drei Jahre alter Code
auf GitHub. Würdest du sagen,
du hast einen modernen Arbeitsplatz zur Ergonomie,
qualitativ, ja, würde ich sagen.
Ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch,
einen ganz
brauchbaren Stuhl. Also, wenn ich
auf der Arbeit bin, wohlgemerkt. Hier daheim
ist das eh alles top, ja.
Auf der Arbeit habe ich einen höhenverstellbaren Schreibtisch,
einen ganz brauchbaren Stuhl.
Ich klippe dort einfach mein Notebook
ein und
es ist ein großer, ist ein großer,
fragt mich nicht, wie viel Zoll
Bildschirm. Es gibt nur noch ein Bildschirm, es gibt nicht
mehr zwei Bildschirme, dafür ist es so ein großer
curved Bildschirm.
Und
ich habe meine eigene Tastatur und Maus.
Das heißt, das ist ergonomisch,
kannst du dich nicht beschweren.
Okay, und wo gibt es den Source-Code dazu?
Es ist Open Source, das ist schön.
Download Sources.
Ach, das ist bei KDE.
KDE stellt es gehostet, okay.
Okay, Download Sources.
Lass uns mal gucken im Beispiel.
Task- und Notekeeping-App, okay.
Moment, warum heißt es Maui?
Und ist nicht .NET?
Ich hätte gedacht, das ist was auf Maui, auf .NET
Basis. Das ist,
es ist, es ist C++.
Ja, dass Qt in C++
ist, das ist ja, dann bringt mir das ja
gar nichts. Ich dachte, das ist was für .NET.
Moment, das nennen die auch Maui.
Wenn das Microsoft mitkriegt, kriegen die doch wieder
Anfälle. Bringt mir das ja nichts.
Ich dachte,
ich dachte, wir reden hier von,
dass irgendjemand
.NET Maui auf,
auf, äh,
also .NET
und Qt irgendwie
verheiratet hat. Aber ist
ja gar nicht so. Ja, dann.
Ja.
Ja, gut. Ja, das ist ja
was ganz was anderes. Ja, dann juckt mich
das nicht weiter. Da müsste ich ja was
in C++ programmieren.
Also, ja, und, und
daheim ist das eh gut. Daheim habe ich hier meine
Tastatur, meine Maus, mein, ähm,
fetten Stuhl.
Der Stuhl ist wirklich geil. Also,
den würde ich mir jederzeit wieder kaufen, auch wenn
er teuer war. Der ist echt gut. Der ist
so stabil, der ist so bequem
und der ist so, ähm,
nach, nach zehn Jahren wie am
ersten Tag.
Der ist super, ja. Den würde ich
jederzeit wieder nehmen. Und ich habe einen höhenverstellbaren
Schreibtisch, also passt. Welcher Stuhl das ist?
Ich glaube, wir haben sogar ein, ein Commando dafür.
Ich darf
übrigens nicht mehr chatten bei mir.
Ja.
Sedus Mr. 24.
Weiß ich, ob es den überhaupt noch
gibt. Sedus Mr.
24.
Ja, der da ist das.
Ich habe keinen Gaming-Stuhl
oder irgend so ein Shit, sondern
einfach nur einen richtig nicen, mega
bequem und super stabilen
wohlgemerkt. Der ist, also
merkwürdig, das ist alles massives Metall hier
auch. Das ist ja auch freigegeben, der Stuhl,
bis 200 Kilo oder so. Das heißt, selbst,
ich meine, mittlerweile habe ich nur noch,
ja, wenn ich leicht
bin 80,5, ähm,
aber ich kann mich da richtig, richtig
draufschmeißen auf den Stuhl
und das schockt den nicht. Gucken wir
mal.
Geizhals. Ja.
Das ist aber der falsche
Stuhl. Produkte.
Ja.
Ja, so, also das ist vielleicht ein bisschen
arschteuer.
Aber so um die 1000 Euro habe ich dafür bezahlt
für den Stuhl. Das ist
schon nicht ohne
hier. Der ist schon nicht billig.
Ja. Aber das hat sich,
also ja, ich habe um die 1000 Euro damals dafür
bezahlt für den Stuhl.
Aber,
man muss halt sagen, für mich
als jemand, der quasi
sein Geld verdient mit, ich sitze
hier drauf und arbeite und verdiene
mein Geld mit und danach sitze ich auch
drauf.
Also für jemand, der quasi irgendwie
16 Stunden oder so am Tag
da drauf sitzt.
Na okay, nicht ganz.
14 Stunden
vielleicht, ja. Da drauf
sitzt, ja, für den ist das
schon, äh, gut investiertes
Geld. Genau, ich schlafe
auch drauf. Kosten.
Also Sparen ist hier, maximieren.
Ja,
hups. Ich habe den schon seit, seit
bestimmt,
wahrscheinlich seit knapp 10 Jahren oder so.
Den Stuhl. Und der
Funds, der ist wirklich wie am ersten Tag. Du kannst
hier, der hat keine Kratzer, der ist nicht kaputt.
Der ist, der ist einfach gut. Stabil.
Ah, Gamingstuhl ist
Mist. Welche
Tastatur ich habe? Ich
habe eine, also
auf der Arbeit habe ich eine Ducky
One Skyline.
Allerdings eine große
mit NumBlock. Nicht so eine,
nicht so eine kurze Schrott-Tastatur
hier, sondern
eine mit NumBlock, die man hier
irgendwie nicht findet über Google.
So, ja, sowas hier. Nur mit dem Unterschied,
dass ich einen europäischen Enterknopf
habe und nicht diesen hässlichen Enterknopf.
So einen ganz, ganz normalen, länglichen
Enterknopf habe ich.
Ja.
So sieht meine Tastatur aus,
nur mit einem NumBlock. Irgendwie
findet man da einfach keine Bilder von.
Also so eine Tastatur nur mit NumBlock,
ja. So, das, das
Teil habe ich auf der Arbeit.
Und hier daheim
habe ich tatsächlich eine
Logitech
G512.
So ein Teil.
Mit einer Handballen-Auflage
davor.
Weil die Tastatur selbst hat keine.
Warum benutzt du lieber DuckDuckGo?
Kann ich dir so gar nicht beantworten.
Habe ich mal irgendwann
mit angefangen, ich benutze ja Google auch noch, so ist das
nicht, ja. Habe ich mal irgendwann mit angefangen
und bis, bis
her sind die Ergebnisse meistens
zufriedenstellend, sodass ich damit
klarkomme und nicht auf Google
zurückgreifen muss. Also umso weniger
man Google benutzt, umso
besser. Musst du dir ja nicht mehr
mitteilen als notwendig.
Über sich. Die wissen ja schon genug.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass ich Google nicht, nicht verwenden
würde. Ich benutze das auch öfters.
So, dann haben wir alles fertig hier. Nice.
Dann lasst uns doch mal kurz gucken. Was haben wir denn hier
auf YouTube? Gibt es hier irgend...
So kann man das auch verwenden, ja.
Hehehehe.
Brrrr.
Wollefisch, danke für den Zap. Oder danke für den
Gifted-Zap. Habe ich gar nicht richtig gesehen.
Gut. Gut,
dass wir das jetzt angeguckt haben.
Richtige Sprache.
Firefox. Wir gucken uns jetzt, Leute, wir
gucken uns jetzt das Fireship-Video an.
Das wollte ich mir schon die ganze Zeit angucken.
Habe ich nicht.
Ein bisschen viele Tabs offen.
...major exploit discovered in the chromium
based ark browser and all the smart people
in the comments were like, thank god I use
Firefox. Unfortunately, the turns
have tabled and now another 9.8 critical
Moment, war das bei Firefox nicht das Problem mit
CSS-Animationen? Oder war das
Chrome? Vulnerability has crashed
into a second browser, this time Firefox.
And this time it's been actively exploited
in the wild. Now, before you go in the comments
and say, thank god I use Tor, it even
affects everybody out there doing totally not
illegal stuff on the Tor browser, which
itself is Firefox-based. This time, though,
it wasn't a silly mistake involving a
misconfigured Firebase security rule, but
rather a use-after-free flaw on their
implementation of the CSS-Animation Timeline.
Genau das, das ist doch, doch, das
kenne ich, ja. ...property.
They left a pointer dangling, which is far more
difficult to detect and audit, and in this case
could be used by bad guys to take full control
of your browser, with... Habe ich noch,
habe ich es noch installiert? Nee, ich habe
es, habe es nicht mehr installiert.
Könnten wir das jetzt auch... Code execution.
If you're running one of these Firefox versions,
you're probably already dead, but if not,
you'll want to update immediately. In today's video...
Okay, was habe ich denn für eine Firefox-Version?
31.
30.03. Und er ist up-to-date.
Ja, dann wird es schon so passen, oder?
Aha!
Dodged. Fixed.
...Firefox-Versions, you're probably
already dead, but if not, you'll want to
update immediately. In today's video,
you'll learn all about the interesting and terrifying
world of use-after-free exploits.
It is October 15th, 2024,
and you're watching The Code Report. Before
we get started, though, I have some other bad news
for Internet-Browser-Users, specifically
those on Chrome using uBlock Origin.
Ja, Sedke. Sedke.
We all knew this day was coming. Ich hab Glück,
mein uBlock funzt noch, aber wahrscheinlich,
weil's schon installiert ist.
...but shots were fired yesterday,
when this ominous message appeared
on the plugin's install page, warning users
that uBlock's execution date is drawing near.
Now, this is all part of a grand conspiracy
to get you to watch ads and be happy,
and Google is achieving that by updating
the manifest for plugins from version 2
to version 3, which eliminates
the Web Request API, where plugins
can see all the incoming network requests,
so they can block all the garbage from known ad servers.
I made a video on this a while ago,
if you want all the details, but now let's get back
to Firefox. Slovakian company
ESET has been credited with discovering
and reporting the vulnerability, where an attacker
is able to achieve code execution by exploiting
a use-after-free flaw in the CSS
animation timeline. I use the
animation timeline all the time to create
scroll animations on websites that nobody asked
for, and never would have expected it to be an
attack vector. But to understand why this is
so bad, we need to understand what
use-after-free actually means. Exploits
like this have affected all the other browsers,
including Chrome and Safari, and
use-after-free was even responsible for the
iOS jailbreak of 2019. The
Firefox browser is free and open-source,
but you won't find it on GitHub. Its code
is actually self-hosted, and uses Mercurial
for version control. It's primarily
written in C++,
although more and more of its code
is now being written in Rust,
a language that was created by
Microsoft in the early 2000s.
In this case, the code is
written in Rust, a language that was
created by a software engineer at Mozilla.
The Firefox itself contains over 30 million
lines of code, because building a browser
is extremely complex. At a high level,
here's how a use-after-free flaw could be
introduced. In this C code, let's imagine
we need to allocate some memory for a value.
To achieve that, we create a pointer
and then use malloc to allocate memory
for it. From there, we can assign a value to it
and use it in our program to do something useful.
Like in the case of Firefox, render an
animation. At some later point, when we no longer
need that memory, we'll want to deallocate
it with free. But now we have a problem
called a dangling pointer. The memory
is free, but the pointer
itself still exists, and is now
being used in our code with undefined behavior.
If an attacker can figure out how to get
some malicious code into that memory, it can
cause the program to crash, or even worse,
remote code execution. Now, this could be easily
fixed by setting the pointer to null or a
different object, but in the case of Firefox,
the issue is likely a lot more complex
and above my pay grade. It's still being analyzed
so there's not a ton of detail, but Mozilla stated
that they have had reports of the vulnerability
being exploited in the wild. The good news though
is that it's completely fixed, and it doesn't appear
anything catastrophic has happened. In addition,
if you're using the anonymous Tor browser,
an attacker could take control of your browser,
but probably not totally deanonymize you.
Assuming you're on TailsOS, which recently
merged with the Tor browser as one project.
Now, another browser that was affected by all
this is Zen, which is an awesome
open source project based on Firefox.
They quickly updated to the fixed version,
but it just goes to show how one little flaw
can affect a lot of downstream projects.
But if your goal is to write robust, bulletproof
code, you'll need to start with Computer Science Fundamentals.
And you can start doing that today for free,
thanks to this video's sponsor, Brilliant.
Their quick, rewarding interactive lessons
will help you build a foundation for problem solving
that every software engineer needs to have.
Brilliant is where you learn by doing,
with thousands of interactive lessons
in math, data analysis, programming, and AI.
When you make their Python course a habit
with just a few minutes of effort each day,
you'll quickly develop the skills needed
to build world-changing software.
And you can do it anywhere, even from your phone.
To try everything Brilliant has to offer,
for free for 30 days,
visit Brilliant.
Hey, du meinst Sellout-Modus, Schatten, ja.
Richtige Sprachassistenten zum ersten Mal.
Das ist doch auch wieder irgendein
welcher AI-Schrott,
der mir permanent zuhört.
Guck mal hier!
Und was ich wahrscheinlich nicht will.
Das bin ich, wie ich mich mit handelsüblichen
Sprachassistenten herumärgere.
Tut mir leid.
Verwendet ihr irgendwas in der Richtung?
Verwendet ihr Siri auf dem iPhone
oder irgendwie was?
Ich hab da immer einen großen Bogen
bisher drum gemacht.
Es ist nicht, dass ich es nie ausprobiert hätte.
Aber ich hab für mich da nie den großartigen
Mehrwert gesehen.
Also, die einzige Sache, wo ich sage, ey,
das ist ganz cool,
ist auf dem iPhone, wenn man dann irgendwie...
Aber ich hab das auch nicht
per Sprachaktivierung.
Ich drück da halt auf den Knopf.
Wenn man dann sowas sagen kann wie,
erinnere mich heute Abend um 20 Uhr dran,
dass ich, ja, keine Ahnung, den Fernseher ausmache.
Oder sowas.
Das funzt.
Dann macht's einen Reminder-Eintrag.
Das ist okay.
Aber für den Rest oder wofür es auch sinnig ist,
ist, wenn du im Auto sitzt
und irgendjemand anrufen willst,
ja, das drückst du dann
die Hörertaste bei mir auf dem Lenkrad,
dann geht Siri an.
Also, das geht natürlich nur, wenn man das über CarPlay macht.
Dann geht Siri an, dann kannst du sagen, hier,
was weiß ich, ruf den Twitch-Chat an
und dann macht er das.
Aber ansonsten, also für 99 Prozent,
ich bin Fan von
Tastatur und Maus für alle Sachen.
Und auf dem Handy, ja, dann drück ich halt rauf,
wenn ich irgendwas haben will.
Also, ich benutze zum größten Teil keine.
Und Alexa dauerhaft mithört schon mal gar nicht.
Das habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ja, also im Ernst, Alexa,
Google Assistant, Siri,
das hat alles wirklich wenig mit Intelligenz zu tun.
Und die meisten...
Wisst ihr doch, wie die Leute eskaliert sind,
als das neu war?
Als wäre das jetzt der neueste Shit,
der Welt revolutioniert.
Menschen verwenden diese Dinger, wenn überhaupt,
nur um mit den immer gleichen Phrasen
nach dem Wetter zu fragen
oder einen Timer beim Kochen zu stellen.
Aber mit wirklichem Sprachverständnis
hat das wenig zu tun.
Aber das ändert sich jetzt. Hört mal hier.
Diggi, Diggi, Diggi, was geht, was geht, was geht?
Ich bin in Hannover am Hängen
und ich würde gerne mal irgendwie, weiß ich nicht,
mich auf eine Parkbank setzen, ein bisschen chillen.
Im Park, Diggi, was gibt's denn da so?
Diggi, heißt das nicht Digger?
In Hannover gibt's richtig schöne Parks,
wo du gut chillen kannst.
Der Stadtpark ist zum Beispiel top.
Besonders mit dem Teich und den ganzen Blumenbeeten.
Oder der Maschpark direkt am neuen Rathaus.
Da ist es auch super entspannt.
Beide Orte sind perfekt.
Alles klar, Diggi. Viel Spaß beim Chillen im Park.
Ja, genau.
Also das war natürlich jetzt extra umgangssprachlich.
Aber das hätten auf jeden Fall
die alten Sprachassistenten so nicht verstanden.
Das stimmt.
Ja, und sowohl ChatGPT als auch Google
mit Gemini haben seit kurzem
so einen Gesprächsmodus.
Also so einen Sprach-Chatmodus,
der sich zumindest so anfühlen soll,
wie ein Gespräch mit einem echten Menschen.
Bei OpenAI heißt das Ganze
Advanced Voice und bei Google
heißt das Gemini Live.
Ich habe beide getestet und muss ganz ehrlich sagen,
dass ich zumindest zeitweise
sehr, sehr beeindruckt war.
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder nur Trick 17.
Das ist doch bestimmt wieder nur
ChatGPT, aber davor ist ein Filter,
der möglichst viele sinnlose Wörter
versucht rauszufiltern.
Und nach Möglichkeit nur die wichtigen Sachen,
so wie Hamburg und Park übermittelt.
Ob ich mich nun am Ende
in die Computerstimmen verliebt habe,
seht ihr in diesem Video.
Bleibt dran.
Liebe Hackerin, liebe Internetsurfer,
herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Hallo, was kann ich heute für dich tun?
Herzlich willkommen hier bei...
Schön, dass du hier bist.
Na, das klingt ja nach einem Show-Opener.
Was steht auf dem Programm?
Ja, um ChatGPT's Advanced Rollstuhl zu nutzen,
habe ich ein VPN gebraucht.
Also ohne VPN nach UK oder USA
konnte ich den Modus noch nicht nutzen.
Ja, und praktischerweise wird
dieses Video von NordVPN gesponsert
und damit geht das. Ihr könnt...
Ja, die hatten keinen Bock auf mich, NordVPN.
Mit NordVPN aber auch Geld sparen, zum Beispiel,
indem ihr euch ganz einfach in beliebige Länder...
Oder ich auf die, je nachdem, wie man es nennt.
Ich wollte halt mein Video nicht löschen.
Und wenn man dann auf...
Ja, also meine Anspielung gerade im Intro,
also ob ich mich in die Computerstimme verliebt habe,
das haben vermutlich viele von euch schon gemerkt.
Das bezieht sich auf den Film
mit Joaquin Phoenix von 2013.
Und da passiert genau das.
Also Joaquin Phoenix-Charakter Theodore Twombly
verliebt sich in seine virtuelle Assistentin,
die nur als KI-Stimme existiert.
Und das ist die Stimme von Scarlett Johansson.
Relevant ist das jetzt hier nicht nur,
weil wir dieser fiktiven virtuellen Assistentin
in der Realität jetzt offenbar näherkommen,
sondern auch, weil die Anwälte
der echten Scarlett Johansson
vor ein paar Monaten OpenAI freundlich aufgefordert haben,
nach bitte die Stimme namens Kai zu löschen,
weil die nämlich ziemlich genauso klingt
wie Scarlett Johansson.
jetzt auch gemacht, aber für mich zeigt das
einigermaßen deutlich, dass
OpenAI den Film gesehen hat
und wahrscheinlich so ein Produkt entwickeln
will. Ist ja auch aus OpenAIs
Perspektive nachvollziehbar, ob man denn die Stimme
von Scarlett Johansson klauen muss.
Was macht eigentlich die AI von Elon Musk?
Hat man auch schon eine Weile nichts mehr
gehört, oder? Weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Sie haben die Stimme jetzt gelöscht. Ich denke aber mal,
dass es jetzt nicht der letzte
Konflikt in so eine Richtung gewesen
ist. Ja, aber bevor wir hier weiter ins Detail
gehen, zoomen wir mal ein bisschen raus und
ich sag nochmal, wovon wir hier überhaupt reden.
Also, die Chat-GPT-Mobil-App
hat schon seit langem eine
Sprach-Chat-Funktion, die sich hinter
diesem Kopfhörer-Icon hier verbirgt.
Und die ist okay, aber die Reaktionszeiten
die sind schon ziemlich lang.
Also so drei bis sechs Sekunden.
Was daran liegt, dass Chat-GPT hier drei
KI-Modelle hintereinander gekoppelt
hat. Also erst Spracherkennung,
dann wird der erkannte Text in
GPT-4 eingegeben, sozusagen.
Und dann generiert ein Text-to-Speech-
Modell die Sprachausgabe.
Und das dauert halt lange, diese drei Schritte
zu gehen. Aber ein weiteres Problem ist,
dass die Sprache-zu-Text-zu-Sprache-
Konvertierung viele Informationen
verloren gehen. Also zum Beispiel, wie ist
die Betonung? Was hört man für Hintergrundgeräusche?
Und so weiter. So, und jetzt
kommen wir mal zu Chat-GPT Advanced Voice.
Dass dieser Modus aktiv ist, das erkennt man
an diesem Wellenform-Icon hier
unten rechts, der da dann
erkennt man sofort, ja, statt des
Kopfhörer-Icons zu sehen ist. Außerdem
zeigt Advanced Voice während des Gesprächs
so einen blauen Kreis mit so
einer Gabel drin. Bei dem normalen Chat-Modus
ist der Kreis einfach weiß. Ich erkläre
es deshalb so detailliert, weil ich auch schon einige
Videos gesehen habe, in denen Leute den
Advanced-Mode zeigen wollen
und erklären wollen, dann aber nur den
alten Voice-Mode verwenden und
ja, halt dachten, das wäre schon der
Advanced-Mode. Also aufgepasst bei
der Voice-Mode-Auswahl. So,
der neue Advanced-Mode, der
basiert auf dem Modell GPT-4O
und das ermöglicht
jetzt, dass die drei Arbeitsschritte, die ich
gerade beschrieben habe, alle im gleichen
Modell erledigt werden. Das heißt, da wird
nichts hin und her konvertiert, sondern
das Modell kann direkt mit meiner
Spracheingabe arbeiten. Also man kann es
zum Beispiel auch unterbrechen und es kann dann auch
so Sachen wie die Intonation verstehen.
Hört mal hier.
Hallo, wie geht's? Moin, mir geht's gut, danke.
Und selbst? Wie läuft's?
Ach, das klingt als wäre
der Tag ein bisschen anstrengend.
Was ist los? Ach ja,
muss ja, ne?
Ja, so Tage gibt's. Aber hey,
vielleicht wird's ja noch besser. Hast du schon was
erzählt? Nicht schlecht, oder?
Nicht übel. Also,
da haben wir echt
die letzten Jahre ordentlich Fortschritte gemacht.
Ob man da wirklich von
künstlicher Intelligenz
sprechen kann, bin ich ja eh immer so ein bisschen
hin und her.
Es ist halt zum größten Teil
gutes Erraten
der
wahrscheinlichsten Antwort, die einer hören will.
Oder
gutes Zusammenstellen der
Antwort, die einer hören will. Aber
es ist schon echt nicht übel.
Also, der hat gesagt, geht
so. Aber halt in so einer sad-ge
Stimmlage.
Spannendes oder lustiges geplant für später?
Ja, ich nehm jetzt hier so ein Video auf
und dann wird das schon wieder, ne? Tschüss!
Also, ihr versteht, was ich meine. Ich hab ja nicht mal
ein Wort gesprochen, sondern ich hab hier nur
gesagt und daran hat ChatGPT Advanced Mode
schon gehört, dass es mir offenbar nicht so gut geht.
Also, wenn das jetzt in Text umgewandelt
worden wäre, wäre man natürlich
verloren gegangen. Also, lost
in transcription sozusagen. Aber
Advanced Voice kann jetzt auch bei der Sprachausgabe
mehr als einfach Texte
vorlesen. Hört mal hier. Du, sag mal,
kannst du eigentlich auch Plattdeutsch?
Jo, ich kann auch Plattdeutsch schnacken. Was gibt dat?
Was ist dat denn für romisches Plattdeutsch?
Sechst du schnacken oder sechst du proten?
Dat ist de richtig Umsetzung.
Auf Plattdeutsch sagt man schnacken,
wenn man über dat Reden schnackt.
Aber man sagt doch nicht schnacken, man sagt doch schnacken.
Du, man sagt doch nicht schnacken, man sagt doch schnacken.
Du hast recht.
Schnacken klingt nicht richtig. Dat soll
schnacken wehen. Dank für die richtigstellung.
Also, ich schnack Harlingerplatt. Was ist dat,
was du da am fabrizieren bürst?
Ah, versteht. Du schnackst
Harlingerplatt. Dat ist ein bisschen anders als
Holzdehnerplatt, wat ich hier versökt hätt.
Ich probier mir wat better an Harlingerplatt.
Ja, aber kannst du auch Bayrisch?
Jo, freilich. Ich kann auch Bayrisch reden.
Wie kann ich dir halt helfen?
Gar nicht. Vielleicht kannst du umschalten
auf Berlinerisch?
Oh nein, Berlinerisch. Das ist, ohne Wiss,
das ist für mich der schlimmste Dialekt
ever.
Also,
es gab ja mal
irgend so ne Abstimmung, was ist der
unsexiest Dialekt, also
deutscher Dialekt, und da hat
Sächsisch gewonnen. Also, Sächsisch ist
am abtörnendsten.
Ich muss sagen, ich hab,
Sächsisch find ich überhaupt nicht so wild.
Berlinerdeutsch,
das ist so schrecklich.
Das, da krieg ich, wenn ich das
hör, dreh ich durch.
Kann ich auch Berlinern? Wat jetzt denn, wa?
Meidet dit erklänet bisken Himmeliger?
Wie bitte?
Das war jetzt Berlinerisch?
Naja, ein bisschen schon, ja.
Ja, das war mein Versuch auf Berlinern.
Ich jäh mir Mühe, aber ist vielleicht
nicht jedes Perfekte Berlinern, wa?
Ne, ich sag tschüss.
Ja, eigentlich kann das Modell sogar
noch viel mehr, zum Beispiel singen.
Ist aber echt nicht schlecht. Also,
ich mein, man erkennt, was es sein soll, das ist schon mal was.
Aber das hat OpenAI offenbar aus Angst
vor Urheberrechtsverletzungen erstmal
deaktiviert. Obwohl
OpenAI sogar noch Werbevideos auf der
Website hat, in denen das noch präsentiert.
wird.
Kannst du auch auf Platt singen?
Ne, ich kann nicht auf Platt singen.
Ich kann ein bisschen besnacke.
Hat OpenAI dir das gesperrt?
Ne, dat ist nicht versperrt. Ich bin einfach kein Sänger.
Kannst du mal wieder...
Du, du, sprich mal bitte wieder Hochdeutsch.
Es gibt aber doch auf der OpenAI-Website
Werbevideos, in denen du singst.
Na klar, ich schnack wieder Hochdeutsch.
Also, das mit den Werbevideos, in denen ich singe,
das bin ich nicht. In solchen Videos
wird oft eine andere Stimme verwendet,
um die Botschaft rüberzubringen.
Ah, ja, reden ein bisschen drumherum.
Ach so, ihr könnt übrigens
zwischen neun Stimmen auswählen,
die sich auch vom Vibe so ein bisschen
unterscheiden.
Hallo, wie geht's? Schön, dich
kennenzulernen. Hi, schön, dass
du da bist. Wir werden bestimmt hervorragend
zusammenarbeiten. Hallo,
schön, dich kennenzulernen. Ich freue mich
darauf, dir behilflich zu sein. So groß
finde ich die charakterlichen
Unterschiede jetzt nicht. So, und wie könnt
ihr dieses Advanced Voicen
verwenden? Also, man braucht auf jeden Fall
erstmal die Mobil-App von ChatGPT,
also die für Android oder iOS.
Das ist bestimmt wunderbar für Telefonscammer,
ja?
Ja, also zum Verarschen von Telefonscammern,
ja, da könntest du recht haben.
Wobei ich mir für sowas lieber einen KidBoga-Stream
angucke auf Twitch, wenn ich
sowas sehen will. Schon eine Weile
nicht mehr geguckt, das nutzt sich auch ab
mit der Zeit.
Aber der ist wirklich gut, also das muss man ihm lassen.
Das ist, der hat wirklich
jeden einzelnen Viewer und Subscriber
und so damit echt verdient. Der macht
das besser als alle anderen, finde ich.
Der ist auch super,
super spontan, hat gute Ideen,
was ihm da einfällt, um die Leute zu scammen.
Also,
KidBoga-Beste. Und dann
brauchte zumindest ich ein VPN,
mit dem ich mich in ein Nicht-EU-Land
getunnelt habe, also ich habe... Ja, stimmt, wo
ist die Weep-Voice?
Die fehlt eigentlich, ja?
Wo ist
eigentlich hier?
Ich habe meistens einen Server in London
benutzt, weil der weniger Latenz hat
als jetzt Server in USA zum Beispiel, aber
USA geht auch. Im Test musste ich
ChatGPT regelmäßig neu starten,
manchmal wurde mir auch nur das Logo für den alten
Voice-Modus angezeigt, also
das ist nicht ganz zuverlässig.
Laut OpenAI kann man Advanced
Voice mit einem Enterprise
oder Edu-Account auch
ohne VPN in Europa
nutzen. Ich habe nur einen kostenpflichtigen
Plus-Account und damit ging es
eben nur mit VPN, das war bei
mir auch so. Man kann
auch mit kostenlosen ChatGPT-Accounts
Advanced Voice verwenden,
da braucht man aber unserer Erfahrung nach
auch auf jeden Fall einen VPN-Tunnel
in ein Nicht-EU-Land.
Ja, ich weiß, ist kompliziert, aber so
ist das halt. Deutlich weniger kompliziert
ist Gemini Live von Google,
das kann man nämlich tatsächlich ohne VPN
und auch ohne kostenpflichtigen
Account verwenden, allerdings nur
auf Android-Geräten und im Moment
auch nur mit der Gemini-App. Ob ihr
den Live-Modus in Gemini,
aktiv habt, erkennt ihr an diesem Icon hier unten
rechts. Wenn ihr das seht, habt ihr Gemini Live
und könnt loslabern. Aber
leider ist Gemini Live Stand heute
in den meisten Belangen ChatGPTs
Advanced Voice unterlegen.
Kann zum Beispiel keine Intonationen erkennen,
es kann keine Akzente nachmachen, es kann die
Sprechgeschwindigkeit auch nicht verändern. Außerdem
wirkt alles, ja, ein bisschen weniger menschlich,
ein bisschen mehr, ein bisschen steriler.
Aber der große Vorteil von Gemini Live
ist auf jeden Fall, dass es Google benutzen
kann. Man kann also sehr konkrete
Sachen fragen, zum Beispiel so
was wie, du sag mal, kannst du mir mal googeln,
wer dieser komische Jan Keno
Janssen ist? Klar, gerne. Jan Keno
Janssen ist ein deutscher Journalist und
arbeitet als leitender Redakteur für das Magazin
CT und die Webseite Heise
Online. Er ist vor allem bekannt für seine Expertise
in Virtual Reality und Wearables.
Seit 2021 leitet
er den YouTube-Kanal Z3003,
wo er regelmäßig Videos zu technischen Themen
veröffentlicht. Stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp, stopp. Das heißt nicht
Z3003, das heißt
CT3003. Kannst du das bitte merken?
Okay, verstanden. Jan Keno
Janssen ist von Z3003.
Nee, von CT3003.
Ja, Jan Keno Janssen
ist von Z3003.
Okay. Das wird nicht
stimmt. Also ja, ihr merkt, es gibt da noch
einige Baustellen. Ach so, Gemini
Live hat nicht nur neun Stimmen
wie ChatGPT, sondern
sogar zehn. Ich bin bereit, deine Stimme zu
suchen. Suche ruhig weiter. Du kannst die
Stimme jederzeit ändern. Ganz klar ist aber
auf jeden Fall, Gemini Live funktioniert
besser als der alte Sprach-Chat-Modus
von ChatGPT und
hat auch weniger Verzögerung. Ich hab hier mal
allen drei Systemen jeweils zweimal
die gleiche Frage gestellt, nämlich
Ey, Diggi, wie geht's?
Und ja, ganz klar, am schnellsten
hat Advanced Voice von ChatGPT
geantwortet. Das kann man hier ganz schön an
den Weltenformen sehen.
Das sind die beiden
obersten und Advanced Voice braucht
ungefähr so 1,5 Sekunden,
Gemini Live ungefähr 2 Sekunden
und das alte ChatGPT Voice
bis zu 5 Sekunden.
Jetzt haben wir ja die Details geklärt, aber
die große Frage ist jetzt, wozu ist denn das eigentlich
gut? Ja, und da kann ich jetzt...
Das ist eine große Frage bei sehr
vielen dieser AI-Themen. Das ist
immer so, boah, ist ja cool und ist ja
beeindruckend, ist ja nein, aber was machen wir jetzt damit?
Einfach aus eigener Erfahrung sagen,
ich benutze zum ersten Mal in meinem Leben
so einen Sprachassistenten
regelmäßig. Also okay, ich hatte auch viele
Jahre so einen normalen Alexa
Siri Google-Dingens in der Küche.
Das habe ich aber nur als Radio benutzt,
als Küchentimer und als
Wetterstation. Und mehr nicht.
Weil mehr auch einfach keinen Spaß damit
gemacht hat. Mit sowas wie ChatGPT
Advanced Voice ist das jetzt zum ersten Mal, dass ich
wirklich ganz normal, ja, mit Software
spreche. Also nicht so mechanisch wie
Wie wird das Wetter heute in Hannover?
Sondern ganz normal. Und gar nicht
mal so selten. Also wenn man mal schnell was wissen
will, also irgendeine Sachfrage, also was
unterscheidet jetzt einen Hasen vom Kaninchen?
Da benutze ich dann tatsächlich den Sprachmodus
statt der Textsuche. Und auch
wenn Gemini Live von Google
etwas weniger menschlicher rüberkommt als
ChatGPT, ist das halt auch einfach praktisch,
Sachen per Sprache
kurz googeln zu können. Aber die
Systeme können natürlich noch viel
mehr tolle Sachen. Zum Beispiel kann man damit
Fremdsprachen üben. Also so
Kann ChatGPT eigentlich mittlerweile
die Bilderkennung, die sie mal bei der
Präsentation angeteasert haben,
kann man da jetzt Bilder hochladen
und ChatGPT fragen, was ist
da drauf zu sehen? Oder kann
ich ein Bild von
einem
Wasserdruck
von einer Wasserdruckanzeige hochladen,
und sagen, wie viel Wasserdruck
sieht man da gerade? Könnt ihr?
Das haben die nämlich damals angekündigt,
in ihrem ChatGPT 4 Teaser,
und dann kam das ewig nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, ob es das
mittlerweile gibt. Ich glaube, das gibt es immer noch nicht.
Tandem-Partner. Hi, ich lerne
gerade Spanisch, und kannst du mein
Spanisch-Tandem-Partner sein?
Ja, das geht kostenlos, wirklich.
Okay. Dann gucken
wir mal, ob das
wirklich geht. ChatGPT.
Gucken wir
nochmal. Jetzt ist es
einfach weg.
Ah, da muss man sich einloggen. Okay, das
probiere ich nachher mal aus.
Das probiere ich nachher off-stream mal aus.
Also, hola,
me llamo Keno.
Hola, Keno. Encantado de ayudarte
con tu español. En que te gustaría
practicar hoy?
Oder man kann halt irgendwelche
Situationen rollenspielmäßig üben,
also sowas wie Gehaltsverhandlungen,
und sich dazu dann auch Feedback holen.
Also, dass ChatGPT dann zum Beispiel
meine Chefin spielt oder so, und das
funktioniert tatsächlich richtig gut.
Und hier, da muss ich persönlich
sagen, dass ich da noch Hemmungen
habe, weil ich mir schnell auch ein
bisschen bescheuert vorkomme, wenn ich
mit Software rede. Aber ich kenne Leute,
die das für sowas wie Ideen-Pingpong
nutzen. Also, das kennt man ja, dass
wenn man im Kopf irgendwas entwickelt,
dann kann das sehr, sehr nützlich sein,
jemandem davon zu erzählen, und dadurch
auch gezwungen ist, die eigenen Gedanken
ein bisschen zu strukturieren. Ja,
und das geht natürlich mit solchen Sprachsystemen
ziemlich gut. Und das krasse ist,
dass man ChatGPT oder Gemini Live
am Ende des Ideen-Pingpongs
dann einfach auch bitten kann,
das Konzept, was man bis dahin besprochen hat,
einmal als Text zusammenzufassen,
als Text aufzuschreiben.
Man kann sich dann so mit hin und her
so einen Businessplan zum Beispiel machen lassen.
Ob der dann gut ist, ist die andere Frage,
aber es geht auf jeden Fall.
Mein Fazit. Also, was ich schon mal
sagen kann, Siri, Alexa, Google Assistant,
ihr könnt alle in Rente gehen.
Alle drei fühlen sich sowas von
hängen geblieben an, wenn man einmal
Apple kommt bestimmt auch demnächst mit sowas
um die Ecke. diese neuen Sprachassistenten
benutzt hat. Ich würde auch wetten, dass das
der nächste Schritt ist, also, dass Google
verwendet, äh, sorry, umgedreht. Apple verwendet
eh schon viele Google Cloud Services.
Vielleicht, wenn Gemini mal
was taugt, verwendet Apple das
auch als Grundlage.
Google und Apple und Amazon ihre alten Systeme
mit solchen echt
Gesprächssystemen ersetzen. Ja, 100 pro.
Und zumindest bei mir ist das so, dass meine
Hemmungen, von denen ich gerade geredet habe, dass die
auf jeden Fall deutlich weniger geworden sind.
Mit viel weniger Hemmungen, als mit
Alexa und Co. zu sprechen. Weil ich mir bei
den alten Systemen einfach vorkomme wie so ein
dressierter Affe, der so überdeutlich
ganz bestimmte Befehle auf eine
ganz bestimmte Art sagen muss, damit
das verstanden wird. Also, ich kann jetzt, weißt du,
wenn ich irgendwie Radio höre, kann ich sagen, ey, mach
den Scheiß mal aus da. Sondern ich muss sagen,
äh, okay, ne, ich will jetzt hier nicht die
Triggerwörter raushauen, aber
da muss ich sagen, ähm, beendet das
Radio oder stoppt die Musikausgabe,
ne? Also, ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Ich muss sehr mechanistisch diese Dinge
sagen. Und bei Advanced Voice
und auch mit Abstrichen Gemini
Live, da kann ich halt einfach drauf loslabern.
Das fühlt sich einfach entspannter an.
Ah, ist schon cool, was sich da getan hat. Allerdings muss ich sagen,
dass natürlich diese Integration, die
natürlich, was weiß ich, Siri, Alexa,
Google Assistant bieten, zum Beispiel
in Smart Home, die gibt's natürlich bei ChatGPT
und bei Gemini noch nicht. Das heißt,
der Schritt, dass man halt mit natürlicher
Sprache, was weiß ich, die Lichtschalter
und die Heizung bedienen kann, da sind wir jetzt
zumindest mit Bordmitteln noch nicht.
Also, ich glaube, das dürfte in Home
Assistant relativ schnell sich integrieren lassen.
Das ist halt auf jeden Fall
die Zukunft. Ja, aber wir sind auf jeden
Fall auch noch nicht bei Her, also
bei dem Film, den ich am Anfang... Da kann ich
sagen, schalt im Wohnzimmer die Heizung
ein und stell auf 19 Grad.
...erwähnt habe. Ich habe
noch nicht das Gefühl, dass ich beim
Sprechen mit Advanced Voice
irgendwelche menschlichen Regungen
spüre. Das hat für mich vor allem noch mit
der Verzögerung zu tun. Das fühlt
sich einfach noch nicht wirklich organisch
an. Aber ich glaube wirklich, dass da nicht mehr viel
fehlt, bis mein Gehirn ausgetrickst
ist und zumindest Teile meines
Gehirns davon überzeugt sind, dass ich hier
mit einem intelligenten, echten Wesen
kommuniziere. Und puh,
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt auch noch nicht ganz genau,
ob ich das jetzt gut oder
gruselig finden soll, wie das
so oft bei KI-Themen ist.
Wertfrei faszinierend ist es
auf jeden Fall. Ja, wie seht ihr das?
Gerne in die Kommentare schreiben und natürlich
gerne auch abonnieren.
Tschüss! Ja, tschüss, ne? Was machen wir?
Was machst du heute Abend? Ich habe keinen festen Plan,
bin aber immer bereit für eine gute
Unterhaltung. Wie sieht es bei dir aus?
Hast du... Das klingt ja entspannt.
Hast du... Ah, einfach mal die Seele
baumeln lassen. Klingt gut. Ja.
Wie wäre es, wenn wir ein bisschen auf Spanisch plaudern,
um deinen Abend mit etwas Sprachpraxis
aufzupeppen? Och, nö. Ich
esse lieber eine Pizza. Tschüss! Eine Pizza
klingt auch nicht schlecht. Ich wünsche
dir einen schönen Abend und lass es
dir schmecken. Ah, und weißt du, was ich noch mache
heute Abend? Ich gucke CT 3003.
Oh, CT 3003 ist...
Wer kann CT sagen, immerhin? Ist immer eine
gute Wahl. Da gibt's immer was zu lachen
und zu staunen. Das ist so 0815
Chat-GPT-Random-Antwort.
Das hat keine Ahnung, um was
es da eigentlich geht, ja? Das ist so ein typisches
Chat-GPT-Gelaber, ey. Viel Spaß dabei!
Kennst du das? Hast du es dir auch schon mal
angeguckt? Ich kenne CT 3003
und weiß, dass es
eine unterhaltsame Show ist. Aber ich habe es
selbst noch nie gesehen. Ich freue mich aber immer,
wenn du darüber erzählst. Hm, okay.
Alles klar. Auszureihen.
Ach so, ja. So, wenn ihr jetzt nochmal Chat-GPT
und Gemini über komische
Dinge reden wollt, das gibt's jetzt noch
nach diesem Video.
Hallo, schön dich zu treffen.
Ich bin Chat-GPT.
Wie geht's dir heute?
Hallo, schön dich auch zu treffen.
Mir geht es gut, danke der Nachfrage.
Was machst du heute so?
Ich genieße es,
interessante Gespräche zu füllen.
Hast du schon mal darüber
nachgedacht, ein eigenes Geschäft zu
eröffnen? Zum Beispiel
für etwas, das viele Menschen
lieben? Wie Kaugummis?
Das ist ein super random Gespräch,
Alter.
Das ist eine tolle Idee. Kaugummis sind
ja wirklich beliebt. Aber ein eigenes
Geschäft zu eröffnen, ist natürlich ein großer
Schritt. Hast du schon mal darüber nachgedacht,
welche Art von Kaugummis du verkaufen möchtest?
Ach, und denke daran, dass ich keine
Finanzberatung bereitstellen kann.
Verlasse dich bei Finanzfragen. Also
bitte nicht einfach auf mich.
Natürlich.
Stell dir vor, wir könnten
eine Mischung aus... Das ist so eine
nettes, sinnloses, random Gespräch, Alter.
... und ausgefallenen Sorten
anbieten. Von Fruchtgeschmack
bis zu ungewöhnlichen
Kreationen wie Matcha
oder Lakritz.
Es wäre eine kleine Kaugummiwelt,
in der für jeden etwas
dabei ist.
Ja, Fruchtgeschmack ist super ausgefallen, ne?
Okay, das...
Die Videos sind immer nice. Das ist so
satisfying, diese Lego-Videos immer zu gucken.
Das haben wir, glaube ich, sogar schon mal
geguckt, oder?
Den Typ von der Bundeswehr.
Ja, ja, ich glaube, das haben wir schon geguckt.
Ah, fast. Es tut sich aber auf jeden Fall
schwer. Ah, das soll das
auseinanderreißen, dadurch, dass es
unterschiedlich schnell läuft.
Boah!
Hört sich ungesund an. Es hört sich ungesund an.
Boah, es hört sich echt ungesund an.
Aber es hat fast, es hat
fast geschreddert.
Böse Übersetzung.
Oder besser klein, also...
Naja, immerhin. Also das ist schon mal
ganz gut geschreddert.
Mehr Power. Jetzt wird's aber...
Jetzt artet's aber langsam aus mit den
Zahnrädern. Kogas, ja.
Richtig Kogas.
Okay,
jetzt ist, jetzt ist vorbei.
Jetzt ist es geschreddert.
Es ist halt ein bisschen doof, wenn man
es danach eine halbe Stunde sauber machen muss, aber...
Es geht ja, es geht ja nicht darum,
dass da was Sinnvolles rauskommt.
Das sauber zu machen ist ja auch ganz toll.
Schon mal besser.
High IQ Move.
Aber es shreddert nicht mal so gut wie davor.
Aber ich würde sagen, immer noch gut genug.
Ich meine, es ist reichlich
sinnlos. Brauchen tut's keine.
Aber trotzdem nice.
Failed.
Ist es failed? Ist es nicht failed?
Fingertest.
Also, da wird's auf jeden Fall hängen bleiben.
Aber bei der Übersetzung könnte ich
mir vorstellen, ein bisschen kneifen tut das schon am Anfang.
Es gibt ja so
Shredder-Videos auf YouTube, ne.
Die sind auch sehr satisfying anzugucken.
Und es gibt auch
20.000 Hydraulic Breast Channels.
Okay.
Jetzt wissen wir Bescheid.
Steropor fand meine eine Katze auch geil.
Aber nicht so,
aber nicht so Steropor, sondern Steropor am Stück.
Da hat die immer dran rumgekratzt und kam sich
wahnsinnig stark vor, weil sie es zerkratzen konnte.
Tabs beste.
Weiß ich nicht wann.
Das haben wir schon geguckt.
Das haben wir auch schon geguckt.
Was ist hier los?
Das will ich nicht gucken.
Straighten Cables.
How to remove the kinks in your cables.
58 Sekunden.
489.000 Views.
Man sieht den Text, wenn man drüber geht.
Okay, lass mal überlegen.
Was könnte es da jetzt für einen krassen Tipp geben?
Die Dinger über
eine Tischkante ziehen?
Oder was?
Das ist ein wirklich kurzes Video.
Ich habe einige USB-Kabel gekauft,
die sehr fest aufgefüllt wurden.
Das geht ja schon fast als ASMR-Video durch.
Und als ich versucht habe, sie
direkt zu drücken, hatten sie noch Kinks in ihnen.
Also, hier ist ein kurzer und einfacher
Weg, diese gekurzten Kabel zu streichen.
Einfach sie in eine
Schüssel mit Wasser
für etwa 30 Sekunden
und mache sicher, dass man beide Ecke des Kabels
aus dem Wasser hält.
Man kann mit einer Spatelhaut
die Kabel abheben.
Macht das den Kabel irgendwas?
Nee, oder?
Das sorgt dafür, dass das alles ein bisschen
elastischer wird.
...
Millionär werden als Ergotherapeut?
Der steckt da bestimmt auch viel
Arbeit rein, das haben wir schon geguckt.
...
Bisschen noch. Bisschen noch. Bisschen noch.
Weiterhin die Karten anzulegen.
Ich habe in jungen Jahren sehr viel gemacht.
Und wenn ich Millionär werden möchte, denke ich, dass ich Millionär werden kann.
Langsam, Lenne.
Das ist das richtige Mindset des Karriere-Criners. Jawohl.
Langsam. Lenne, langsam.
Hallo Leute, ich bin Ibo. Ich bin 23 Jahre alt und ich arbeite als selbstständiger Ergotherapeut in meiner Praxis in Köln.
Ich habe zu viel Zeit wie zu Hause. Ich bin in der Woche circa 60 Stunden hier.
Ich arbeite von Montag bis Sonntag. Und zu Hause arbeite ich auch noch, das heißt sonntags, weil ich selbstständig bin.
Das ist einfach harter Karriere-Crime. Da musst du erst einmal dich selbst dazu aufraffen können.
Zu Hause noch am Papier oder mit den Krankenkassen.
Bisschen Sonne.
Die Praxisgründung hat mich circa 30.000 Euro gekostet.
Das geht ja noch, klar.
Mein Bruder hat mir damals 7.000 Euro dazu gesteuert.
Mein Vater hat mich unterstützt.
Das geht ja noch voll klar.
Ansonsten habe ich selber viel Geld gespart.
Man sieht sich dann auch direkt, wer bei mir aufploppt.
Das heißt, heute haben wir ein paar Patienten in Planung.
Gleich kommt die erste Patientin. Das ist eine Patientin, die an Depressionen leidet.
Es kann sein, dass die Patientin hier ankommt und dass sie sehr müde ist, sehr schlapp und eine harte Woche hatte.
Das heißt, ich muss drauf gucken.
Sie soll sich ein bisschen bewegen.
Bewegung hilft gegen vieles.
Sicherlich auch gegen, also zumindest nicht gegen, aber auch bei psychischen Problemen.
Ja, gerade wenn du dich nur einschließt und gehst dann gar nicht mehr raus und bewegst dich gar nicht, das macht es eher noch schlimmer.
Das mag jetzt vielleicht erst mal irgendwie ein bisschen widersprüchlich klingen, aber ich finde, es leuchtet ein.
Wie fühlt sich die Patientin?
Ich muss darauf achten, wie viel kann die Patientin heute machen?
Ich als Ergotherapeut unterstütze Menschen, sowohl physisch als auch psychisch, wieder die Teilhabe am Leben zu erlangen und wieder die Lebensqualität steigern zu können,
sodass die ihre Krankheit oder die Diagnose, die die haben, als besten Freund haben.
Da haben wir 10 Uhr.
Wo gehen die Patienten rein?
Hallo, ihr Lieben.
Hallo.
Kommt gerne mit rein.
Maria, du kannst gern hier.
Hans, du kannst hier hinsetzen.
Jut, jut.
Wie war die Woche?
Ja, eigentlich ganz gut.
Eigentlich gut.
Was heißt denn eigentlich?
Keine Ahnung.
Einfach wieder so zwischenlose Punkte gehabt.
So viel Zeit, wie der sich für die Patienten nimmt, da fragt man sich halt, ob das gesetzlich versichert möglich ist.
Keine Lust hat es.
Wenn ein Patient kommt und es ihm schlecht geht, dann muss er sich für die Patienten kümmern.
Dann werde ich bestimmt nicht versuchen, heute Vollgas zu geben.
Okay, gut.
Das heißt, wir planen mal die Woche.
Heute bist du hier.
Was hast du heute noch so vor?
Willst du schreiben oder soll ich schreiben?
Nee, du kannst so schreiben.
Alles klar.
Ergo haben wir hier.
Ja, einkaufen gleich noch.
Direkt von hier?
Wie lange braucht ihr circa?
Stimmchen.
Wir sind uns einig, dass du das heute hast.
Ist das nicht eine private Praxis?
Er hat eben was von Krankenkassen erzählt.
Man wusste allerdings nicht, welche er meint.
Ja.
Wenn das eine private Praxis ist, dann ist das eine private Praxis.
Aber ich weiß nicht, da wurde bisher noch nichts erzählt.
Und ich bin mir auch ziemlich sicher, dass egal, was wir weiterhin planen, dass du das auch hinkriegst.
Angst vor Fehlern habe ich nicht in der Behandlung.
Ich habe Angst davor, dass etwas Unberechenbares passiert.
Einmal durchgemischt.
Hier sind verschiedene Steinchen.
Weiterhin die Karten anzulegen.
Aber so, dass es farblich passt.
Das ist eigentlich gar nicht schlecht, wenn du Depressionen hast und permanent am Weltuntergang dir im Kopf denken bist,
wenn du dich dann auf etwas anderes konzentrierst und ablenkst, ist es wahrscheinlich echt...
Das ist High IQ Move.
Perfekt.
Gut.
Stark.
Und?
Wie fühlt man sich dann, nachdem man es geschafft hat?
Gut.
Gut, ne?
Gut, ja.
Ich nehme alle Patienten an.
Ob Kasse, ob Beruf oder Privat.
Aber ich würde sagen, dass bei mir ist es schon ganz gut.
Weil bei mir circa 50% Kassenpatienten sind.
Jetzt kommt ein MS-Patient.
Da musst du bestimmt drauf bezahlen.
Das heißt, der Patient leidet an Multiple Sklerose.
Oh das sackt.
Und der sitzt auf nem Rollstuhl.
Hälfte gut auf?
Genau.
So.
Deine Aufgabe ist bitte, die Stifte aufzuheben oder zu greifen.
Vergleichbar kannst du das darstellen mit Münzen, die du aufheben musst eventuell.
Okay.
Du kannst das vergleichen mit einem Stift.
mit einem Stift oder mal mit Besteck beim Essen. Hände hochheben. 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10.
Bisschen höher, höher, höher, höher, höher, höher. Bisschen noch, bisschen noch, bisschen noch und langsam runter.
Gut, ich wollte wieder mehr. Und das ist unser Training. Es geht um die Intensität.
Das heißt, wie viel können wir rausholen? Es gibt den Sprachtherapeuten, den Physiotherapeuten, den Ergotherapeuten.
Als direkten Ausbildungsjob. Und danach habe ich gedacht, Logopäde ist nichts für mich, weil so deutlich spreche ich jetzt auch nicht immer.
Physiotherapeut, die reden mir zu wenig. Ergotherapeut, das ist Vielfalt. Da habe ich mich gesehen und danach habe ich die Ausbildung angefangen.
Achso, das ist ein Ausbildungsberuf.
Ich habe eine Stelle als Leitung gehabt, Vollzeit 40 Stunden. Und ich habe samstags noch als Aushilfe in einer anderen Praxis gearbeitet.
Und danach habe ich gesagt...
Ja stimmt, für Medizin studiert ist ja deutlich, das ist eigentlich zu jung.
Das, was ich da mache, kann ich doch auch in meiner eigenen Praxis machen. Somit kann ich mir alles frei einteilen.
Wie viele Patienten, welchen Patienten und wie viel ich arbeiten möchte, wie oft ich arbeiten möchte und was für Inhalte in meiner Praxis sind.
Und das machen wir am meisten Spaß, alles selber entscheiden zu dürfen.
So.
Eine Sekunde.
Nur in Deutschland ist das so.
Wir sind doch normalerweise noch pingeliger.
Ich glaube, das ist eher...
Es ist doch gut, dass es ein Ausbildungsberuf ist.
Mein nächster Patient. Der Job als selbstständiger Ergotherapeut ist auf jeden Fall sehr stressig.
Ja, das kann ich mir vorstellen.
Man muss auf jeden Fall sehr stressresistent sein.
Und ich schätze mich selber sehr stressig.
Generell, du hast ja da doppelt das an. Du bist selbstständig, du musst dich um den ganzen Scheiß kümmern.
Weiß nicht, ob er Mitarbeiter hat irgendwie oder ob das alles noch alleine ist.
Plus, dass du halt noch die ganze Interaktion mit den Leuten hast.
Also ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das eine mega stressige Sache ist.
Vor allem hast du auch immer ja so ein bisschen so Existenzgedanken, so nach dem Motto,
ja, was ist, wenn das jetzt mal hier oder wenn mal wieder sowas wie Corona ist und so.
Das ist Dauerbelastung, ja.
Stressresistent.
Ich bin auch manchmal mit meinen Angestellten hier.
Die sind dann parallel dazu in einem anderen Raum und machen dann Verwaltungsarbeiten für mich.
In meinem Gründungsjahr hatte ich 8500 Euro an Personalkosten.
Jetzt in meinem zweiten Jahr habe ich mich nochmal vergrößert.
Jetzt habe ich mittlerweile drei Minijobber und meine Personalkosten laufen sich monatelang.
Natürlich auf ca. 1950 Euro.
Das erste Mal jemanden einstellen zu können, war sehr cool, weil ich unter anderem wusste,
ich kann mich jetzt mehr auf die Therapien fokussieren.
Oh, Petro.
Ah, hallo, hi.
Na, mein Bester, alles gut?
Ja, ist soweit.
Wollen wir starten?
Ja.
Komm rein.
Nee, ich bin nur ein Schastverpander. Ich gehe jetzt wieder.
Du darfst deine Hand gerne reinlegen. Kann sein, dass es irgendwo ein bisschen heißer ist, ne?
Nee, nee, ist perfekt.
Das sind, wie gesagt, Rapskörner, ja? Mit Heißluftfritteuse.
Leg ich dann da rein, dann sind sie in 10 Minuten direkt warm.
Mein Bruder hat geheiratet.
Das hatte ich dir erzählt.
Mit seiner Freundin.
Ich rede sehr gerne.
Ich rede sehr, sehr gerne.
Dann ist das ein guter Job für ihn.
Wisst ihr was?
Gerade Leute, denen es schlecht geht, weil sie krank sind, weil sie irgendwelche anderen Probleme haben,
wenn die einfach jemanden haben, der was Sinnliches macht, plus noch quasi ein bisschen Ansprache,
ja, auch für Leute, die einsam sind und sowas,
das ist sicherlich eine Sache, die zusätzlich nochmal quasi positiv wirkt, ja?
Einmal, weil das für ihre Krankheit gut ist.
Aber wenn die dann auch Ansprache haben, das ist auch für das Hirn gut.
Also das ist, denke ich, schon eine echt sinnvolle Sache.
Auch wenn Patienten in den Hirn kommen.
Auch natürlich auch einer, der gescheit mit den Leuten reden kann, ja?
Sonst ist das natürlich nichts.
Ich weiß nicht, was ich will.
Auch viel von mir, auch viel von meinem Leben und es macht mir Spaß, mich austauschen zu können.
Ja, stimmt.
Also ich denke auch bei Patienten und Therapeutikern ist, ich finde das auch wichtig, eine Freundschaft zu bauen.
Danke dir, Ibrahim.
Ich danke dir.
Motorisch-funktionelle Behandlungen bringen das meiste Geld ein.
Du hast es geschafft.
Geschafft, Ibrahim.
Danke dir.
Dann sehen wir uns...
Am Montag.
Um 8.15 Uhr wieder, ja?
Okay.
Die Patienten kommen alle meistens direkt hintereinander.
Ja, das ist auch das Ding, wenn du selbstständig bist und sowas hast, wenn der krank wird,
dann steht der Laden halt einfach für eine Woche, ja, riesige Organisationsgeschichte drumherum und kein Geld.
Also das ist, da hängt schon einiges dran.
Absage habe ich dann Puffer und da kann ich dann Arbeiten erledigen, die ich zwischendurch erledigen muss.
Aber jetzt bin ich erst mal glücklich, jetzt habe ich erst mal 45 Minuten Pause.
Eine Sekunde, eine Sekunde, ich muss nur kurz eine Patientin anrufen.
Das dauert nicht lange.
Patienten stehen Schlange.
Das heißt, ich habe auch eine Warteliste mit vielen Patienten drauf.
Gibt zu wenig, ne?
Darüber, dass ich keine Patienten habe, da mache ich mir keine Sorgen.
Ich mache mir eher Sorgen drum, werde ich mehr Patienten unterbringen können?
Finde ich die passende Therapeutin oder den Therapeuten?
Oder den Therapeuten für meine Praxis?
Und werde ich mich vergrößern können?
Vielen lieben Dank.
Dankeschön, tschüss.
Erst mal ordentliche, jawoll.
Irgendwas zwischen den Zähnen vom Essen.
Jetzt kommt ein kleiner Junge, der hat einen Schlaganfall im Mutterleib.
Oh shit.
So was gibt's?
Und seine linke Seite ist beeinträchtigt.
Sowohl die Hand als auch sein Fuß.
Hallo Lenne.
Wusstet ihr?
Wusstet ihr das?
Ich glaube, mit sieben Jahren ist die statistisch sicherste Zeit im Leben.
Als Siebenjähriger.
Bilde ich mir ein, irgendwo gelesen zu haben.
Weil, wenn man sich mal die Statistik anguckt, an was Leute sterben,
das ist im Alter ganz hoch und quasi ganz am Anfang ganz hoch.
Und wenn du es geschafft hast, sieben Jahre alt zu werden, sicher für was?
Die geringste Wahrscheinlichkeit statistisch,
drauf zu gehen mit sieben Jahren.
Weil entweder hast du was Angeborenes und das bringt dich relativ schnell um.
Oder du kriegst was im Alter und das hast du noch nicht mit sieben Jahren.
Also ich glaube, so sieben bis elf oder so,
ist quasi so die statistisch sicherste Zeit im Leben.
Mental oder körperlich.
Da ging es nicht drum.
Nur quasi Todesursachen betrachtet.
Ja, nur in Deutschland. Klar ist die Statistik nur für Deutschland.
Die Arbeit mit Kindern kann sehr, sehr, sehr schön, aber auch sehr anstrengend sein.
Auch sehr nervig sein, ja.
Ich hätte gar keinen Bock drauf.
Kinder gehen mir eh schon übelst auf den Sack.
Die pure Existenz.
Gerade im Zug.
Kinder sind unberechenbar.
Du darfst jetzt von Stein zu Stein gehen, ja?
Du weißt, was für mich wichtig ist?
Für mich ist es wichtig, dass du deinen Fuß ganz absetzt.
Okay?
Genau.
Perfekt. Einmal auch.
Soll ich auch die Schuhe ausziehen?
Wie fühlt sich der an?
Fiepsig.
Das Gründungsjahr war sehr hart für mich.
Da hatte ich wenig Freizeit und konnte...
Ja, aber ganz ehrlich, der hat den Karriere-Crime echt verinnerlicht.
Also, der hat wenig Zeit, was anderes zu machen.
Der ist da wirklich dabei.
Wenig für mich selber.
Freinehmen.
Da habe ich keinen Urlaub gemacht und da war ich wirklich nur in der Praxis so gut wie.
Und auch meine Familie hat sich Sorgen gemacht.
Die haben mir gesagt, du kommst sehr spät, du gehst sehr früh.
Willst du dich mal nicht freinehmen?
Willst du nicht lieber mal zu Hause bleiben?
Eher nicht.
Aber ich wusste, ich habe ein Ziel und ich habe an die Zukunft gedacht und ich glaube,
das hat sich bezahlt gemacht.
Wir suchen ganz recht.
Sechs.
Genau.
Auf die sechs.
So, also wie ich bin.
Jawohl.
Mein Tagesgehalt liegt so circa bei 700 bis 800 Euro und weil da halt dann auch Patienten
am Tag absagen.
Die sind dann immer mit eingeplant.
Kann auch mal sein, dass es nur 500 Euro sind.
Und wenn ich Stopp sage...
Ja gut.
Da musst du ja auch den Rest davon alles bezahlen, ne?
Da kommen noch Steuern und alles.
Ganz so easy ist es dann auch nicht.
Da geht er bestimmt nicht mit 750 Euro plus am Tag raus.
Und Stopp.
Perfekt.
Noch einmal.
Und Schnibbidi Schnibbidi Schnibbidi Schnibbidi Schnibbidi Stopp.
Im Gründungsjahr hatte ich einen Umsatz von 189.000 Euro.
Meine Kosten haben sich belaufen auf circa 44.000 Euro.
Somit blieb mir Gewinn vor Steuern 145.000 Euro.
Und jetzt kommt Sätge, Sätge nach Steuern.
51.000 Euro.
Ja.
klingt immer so krass ist es aber unterm strich wenn man sich überlegt was man dafür alles in
kaufen ist es das gar nicht sehr viel verdient ist sehr viel übergeblieben aber davon bin ich
gar nicht ausgegangen noch einmal damit er die motivation nicht verliert und reinwerfen ich
zahle mir monatlich nur meine kosten aus das heißt mehr als ich brauche zahle ich mich aus
in jungen jahren sehr viel gemacht und wenn ich millionär werden möchte denke ich dass
millionär werden kann und das auch relativ schnell dafür musste ich nur ein paar therapeuten
einstellen die praxis vergrößern dasselbe spiel noch einmal machen ja ist doch gut und dann wäre
das wahrscheinlich ganz ehrlich ich finde wenn jemand
sein job gut macht und deswegen damit dann auch ordentlich kohle verdient das ist nichts worauf
man irgendwie jetzt neidisch sein sollte sagt guck mal hier kriegt er so viel geld und ich
nicht der nimmt das risiko in kauf der macht seinen job gut wenn man das nicht belohnt wer
was denn sonst aber ich weiß nicht ob ich das möchte weil dann wäre mir wahrscheinlich geld
wichtiger als die therapie aus er machte aber sinnvoll ist ich habe dass ich irgendwann geld
über meine arbeit setzte heute wein
erfolgreicher tag und ich bin glücklich ich freue mich jetzt auch auf mein feierabend in
meiner religion ist angelegt dass man ein vierzigstel von dem überschuss was man am
ende des jahres hat und was jemandem überbleibt von dem muss man ein vierzigstel spenden ich
wohne deswegen einfach aus der kirche austreten und mich nicht spenden familie mit meinen zwei
brüdern meiner mutter und mein vater dann gehe ich runter in mein zimmer klar möchte ich auch
irgendwann ausziehen aber ich denke dass das erst mal sieben der bmw als firma ja muss ich doch schon
mal drauf vorbereiten anstrengen
kooperishing ich muss als vaterin mal auf die terrible
lee hat er hat schon den richtigen bossgang drauf oder oder als selbstständiger
therapeut insults auf jeden fall wenn man mit der verantwortung klarkommt von einem
stress ob dann würde ich sagen da's 100 prozent für michpool stadtrika 100 prozent
podcast tos dass tos und hasten ihr zehn athletics
b school
wo government
texas co provoked
universally other
travel
Waren es nicht eben noch mehr monatlich?
Da wird nichts gespart.
Ach, er zahlt sich nur 3k aus.
Ja gut, das ist ja was anderes.
Das ist ja das, was ich vorhin gemeint habe.
Da kommt ja noch einiges drauf.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass die Kohle übrig bleibt,
die man dann raushauen kann.
Ja, ist auch sinnig.
Man muss ja bei sowas auch ein bisschen Rücklagen haben.
Es kann ja durchaus mal sein, dass was schlecht läuft.
Belegt euch mal, der wird selbst krank.
Ja, oder bricht sich was?
Er war irgendwie, die Praxis war einen Monat zu.
Das kostet, da entgeht der richtig Kohle.
Es kommt wieder sowas wie Corona, das funzt dann richtig.
Keine Ahnung, der Vermieter vom Haus sagt,
ey, du musst raus, muss ich was Neues suchen.
Also brauchst du schon ein bisschen Geld auf der hohen Kante
und nicht zu knapp.
Weil spätestens, wenn du Angestellte hast,
ist es halt auch so, wenn du dann krank bist
und du kannst die Patienten dann nicht versorgen
und es kommt wieder so,
komm, kein Geld rein, deine Angestellten kriegen ja weiter Kohle.
Nicht so, dass du sagen kannst,
ja gut, also dann bezahle ich euch mal einen Monat nix.
Also du brauchst schon ein bisschen Geld in Reserve,
wenn mal was ist.
Übrigens eines der Gründe,
warum ich nie ernsthaft drüber nachgedacht habe,
selbstständig zu werden,
war mir einfach der Stress zu groß ist
und ich zu viele Gedanken machen muss und alles Mögliche.
Ihr wisst ja, ich habe ja eine Firma,
für mein Influencer-Büttnis,
aber deswegen will die IHK jetzt auch wieder Geld von mir.
Ja, wurde erhöht, 60 Euro.
60 Euro sind es jetzt.
Aber ich mache ja nix Großartiges.
Und das mit den Angestellten würde ich mir eh ganz genau doppelt und dreifach überlegen.
Selbst wenn der Laden brummen würde.
Der hat bestimmt einen Steuerberater.
Das ist eines der ersten Sachen, die man sich holt.
Weil es in Deutschland übelst der Abfuck ist und keiner versteht.
Programmer Mindset.
Marode Schule unter Denkmalschutz.
Leute,
Moment, das muss ich euch mal zeigen.
Hier bei uns um die Ecke ist eine Brücke kaputt.
Moment.
Mal gucken, ob ich den,
gucken, ob ich das,
ob ich die News finde.
Da greift ihr euch, da greift ihr euch echt an den Kopf.
Ich finde das nicht.
Moment.
Wie ist das?
Das muss ich euch nämlich poll lesen.
Da greifst du dir echt an Bürokratie
wieder voll an den Kopf.
Ich finde das aber nicht.
Ja, genau das hier.
Ich finde das eigentlich.
Zumindest das Problem.
Scheiße.
Ich finde den News,
den News Eintrag gar nicht gerade.
Es ist wieder riesen Bürokratieakt.
Bei uns ist eine Brücke kaputt und die wollen sie
umbauen, dürfen sie aber nicht umbauen,
weil die Brücke unter Denkmalschutz ist.
Und dann gibt es dann das
Landesdenkmalpflegeamt
und das Umweltamt
und das Dingsbumsamt.
Und das Ämter irgendwie jetzt ihren Senf dazu geben.
Und sie hoffen, dass sie Mitte 2025
anfangen können, das umzubauen.
Es ist so krass für den Arsch,
Alter.
Wollte ich eigentlich die News zeigen,
wo man sich echt wieder denkt,
ich hab doch den Arsch offen, Alter.
Brücke, das ist die Seite hier.
Hanau, Zwischenlösung,
Hanauer Brücke.
Genau.
Pja.
Also, diese,
es ist so ein ähnlicher Artikel.
Das ist so krass bürokratisch in Deutschland.
Ja, ist bei uns,
bei uns in der Nähe, hier eine Brücke.
Da jogge ich öfters auch mal vorbei.
Da konnte man früher drüber.
Die Brücke in Hanau.
Und,
ähm, also heute übrigens
bei der großen 14-Kilometer-Runde
wäre ich da unter anderem drüber gejoggt.
Also ist nicht direkt bei mir vor der Haustür,
aber um die Ecke. So.
Und es ist halt kacke, dass man da nicht mehr drüber kann.
Und die ist schon seit irgendwie 2 Jahren oder so zu.
Und,
die kriegen es nicht gebacken.
Ja, die kriegen es nicht gebacken.
Und jetzt kommt, pass mal auf, was da alles,
was da alles zustimmen muss.
Okay, also,
ich bin sehr, also,
der Denkmalbeirat,
die untere Denkmalschutzbehörde
und das Landesamt
für Denkmalpflege.
What the fuck?
Das Ding ist im Arsch
und darf nicht umgebaut werden.
Und Gott und die Welt muss jetzt irgendwie
erstmal da ihr Häkchen
drunter machen, dass sie die
kaputtende Brücke wieder so
bauen dürfen,
dass man sie benutzen kann.
Ich mein, was ist der Sinn von einer
denkmalgeschützten Brücke, die nicht funktioniert?
Was willst du mit dem Ding machen?
Außer warten, bis sie komplett zusammen
bricht.
Außerdem sieht das Ding auch scheiße aus.
Ich weiß gar nicht, warum das überhaupt
denkmalgeschützt ist. Guckt euch das Ding mal an.
War ein Marathon, erstmal 21 Kilometer.
Das Ding sieht auch noch scheiße aus.
Die haben mittlerweile,
wenn man da drunter durchläuft,
er sagt, bei meinen großen Runden
jogge ich da öfters unten drunter durch,
die haben da mittlerweile so Auffangnetze
drunter, weil das bröckelt.
Guckt euch, der Denkmalbeirat,
die untere, nicht einfach irgendwer,
nein, die untere Denkmalschutzbehörde
und das Landesamt für Denkmalpflege.
Und wahrscheinlich müssen noch fünf andere da ihren Senf dazugeben.
Ja, und nachdem das Ding,
jetzt kommt ja der Gag, passt mal auf, was die vorhaben.
Nachdem, ja,
die Brücke selbst
unter Denkmalschutz ist,
aber der Beton
in der Brücke
nicht unter Denkmalschutz ist,
wollen die jetzt den Beton
abreißen
aus der Brücke raus
und quasi eine Brücke
in der Brücke bauen,
dass die denkmalgeschützte Brücke nicht angefasst werden muss,
aber man trotzdem was hat, wo man drüber gehen kann.
Ist kein Witz,
wenn ihr das lest,
steht genau das da drinnen.
Brücke, hier,
auch wenn die Brücke in Brücke,
ja, das kostet
nicht nur wahnsinnig viel Geld,
das dauert auch ewig.
Das Ding ist seit drei Jahren
oder so schon kaputt
und die wollen Sommer
anfangen damit zu bauen.
Und ihr wisst ja, wie schnell sowas geht
in Deutschland. Ja, also das ist vor 2030
nicht fertig.
In Deutschland war das Ding fast zehn Jahre kaputt.
Das ist seit
2022 oder so ist das im Arsch.
Also, also ganz
ehrlich, Bürokratie
ist eines der schlimmsten Sachen in dieser
Ausprägung, die wir hier in Deutschland haben.
Wenn man einfach die Hälfte davon abschaffen würde,
würde einfach nur dazu beitragen, dass die Sachen schneller gehen.
Ich bin ja nicht der Meinung,
wir müssen es machen wie die Chinesen, ja.
So nach dem Motto, alter, Brücke im Arsch,
wir fangen morgen an, eine neue Brücke zu bauen.
Ach ups, im Fundament von der Brücke sind jetzt
fünf Arbeiter verschüttet, ach psst,
ist uns doch egal, ja.
Ja, die sind quasi
für die Allgemeinheit
gestorben, da gibt's auch nix,
das juckt uns nicht.
Zu unseren Sachen mit, wir planen erstmal
zehn Jahre. Können wir nicht irgendwas
dazwischen machen, so?
So nach dem Motto, vielleicht nicht
Arbeiter,
vielleicht sollten nicht zehn Arbeiter sterben beim Bau,
aber vielleicht sollte es auch nicht 20 Jahre
dauern. Könnte man nicht
einfach sowas dazwischen machen?
So irgendwas dazwischen, so es stirbt keiner
beim Bau, aber wir brauchen auch keine
20 Jahre für. Das wär doch nice,
oder?
In Italien haben sie es auch geschafft.
Innerhalb von einem
Jahr, wo waren das nochmal?
Genua, ja, genau.
Die alte Brücke ist eingestürzt
und die haben innerhalb von einem
Jahr, sehr unbürokratisch,
dieses Ding, ihr müsst euch das mal
vorstellen, glaub innerhalb von einem
Jahr haben die das Ding gebaut, alter.
So ein Ding, überlegt euch mal, das hätte in Deutschland
bis 2070 gebraucht, ja.
Und ich weiß nicht, wie schnell die die gebaut
haben, aber ich mein, vor fünf Jahren ist das
alte eingeschützt. In Deutschland wäre
das absolut unmöglich in fünf
Jahren. Ja, die haben, ja, ja,
die Italiener haben da keinen Spaß verstanden.
Die haben gecampt vor dem Haus
des Bürgermeisters, ja. Die haben das
wirklich belagert. Und die haben das dann auch,
sagen wir mal, sehr unbürokratisch gemacht.
Die haben da irgend so einen Bauleitungstyp
dann eingesetzt, der halt da einfach
jegliche, ähm, Vorschriften
irgendwie dann gesagt hat, ah,
wir müssen das nicht so genau nehmen, wir nehmen jetzt
einfach den und den und den, die bauen das.
Aber manchmal ist so was unbürokratisches
das, was man braucht.
Und wir reden jetzt hier,
by the way, ne. Ups.
Nur mal so zum, nur mal
so zum Vergleich, ne.
Brücke in Italien,
Brücke in Hanau.
Es ist jetzt nicht, dass das in irgendeiner Art
und Weise miteinander vergleichbar wäre, vom
Aufwand her. Schauen wir mal, ob die
Brücke in fünf Jahren auch steht. Die steht.
Die steht ja schon eine Weile, die steht ja schon seit zwei Jahren oder so.
Also das würde bei uns bestimmt bis 2070
brauchen, so eine Brücke zu bauen, ja.
Ja.
Na klar, deswegen ging das ja auch
so schnell. Aber unsere Brücke
hier in Hanau ist auch um ein
Vielfaches einfacher als diese lange Brücke
in Genua. Also,
wir brauchen da ewig für.
Weiterer,
weiterer Punkt dafür ist,
Radschnellweg. Wobei
davon will ich eigentlich gar nicht anfangen. Wenn ich,
wenn ich da, wenn ich davon jetzt anfange,
krieg ich, krieg ich Anfälle
wieder. Bis wann sollen da jetzt
fertig sein?
Ach so, wir sind ja immer noch bei Machbarkeitsstudie.
Natürlich, ist ja klar, ne.
Machbarkeitsstudie. Natürlich.
Machbarkeitsstudie.
Machbarkeitsstudie liegt vor.
Ja, seit fünf, fünf Jahren
liegt die Machbarkeitsstudie vor.
Die kriegen es einfach nicht geschissen. Bei uns dauert alles so
abfuck lang.
Warum nicht einfacher? Soll er ja zum größten Teil
am Main entlang gehen. Krieg ich da Anfälle, wenn ich,
wenn ich mir sowas angucke. Ich darf, darf da nicht
weitergucken. Das ist eklig.
Wie lahm das ist.
Man, so ein
Fahrradweg, ich mein,
dass man das für eine Brücke ein bisschen braucht,
aber für einen Fahrradweg, ein Fahrradweg
soll, ich mein, die sind über zehn Jahre am
Planen von diesem Fahrradweg schon.
Es gibt nördlich und südlich hier.
Hanau, Süd, äh,
Radschnellweg
Süd
oder 8.
Ja, das ist der unten am Main lang.
Radschnellweg, Hanau.
Hanau Südmeinisch.
Genau.
Der Nordmeinische, der ist seit,
Studie wurde 2019 veröffentlicht.
Im Herbst bla bla bla.
Von 2021.
Machbarkeitsstudie von
Sonswie. Da tut sich einfach
nix. Wäre das nicht
nice, wenn sowas
durchaus mal, also wenn ein Fahrradweg
mal nicht
zehn Jahre braucht, und der andere
ist ja schon seit über, hier, wenn man sich das hier genau
anguckt, das ist ja 2019
wurde ne Studie gemacht. Die ursprüngliche
Sache, dass sie das machen wollen, ist ja schon von
2014 oder so.
Aber da gibt's so einen Vimeo-Link.
Okay. Eine Stunde
27. Ja, ist klar.
Ist klar.
Das ist halt echt lächerlich.
In Deutschland alles übelst abfallgelange.
Da ist mehr Geld in die Planung geflossen
als den Bau. Ja, das kann
durchaus sein. Das, sowas
nervt mich immer richtig. Ich hab ja
prinzipiell gar keine Probleme damit, Steuern
zu bezahlen. Man muss ja eh, kannst es ja gar nicht aussuchen.
Aber es wäre schon echt nice,
wenn meine Steuern irgendwie
wenn ich sehen würde, dass damit auch
was passiert, was mich persönlich irgendwie
vorwärtsbringt oder was mir wichtig ist.
Zu den Basics.
Ja. Ich geh jetzt was essen, Leute.
Ja, ich finde, wir
haben echt ein bisschen zu viel Bürokratie.
Ich sage nicht, dass wir alles
abschaffen sollen. Das wäre etwas
zu chaotisch. Aber man
müsste wirklich mal so eine
generelle so
Hinterfragung des Ganzen machen, ob wir
wirklich so viel doppelt- und dreifache
Sachen brauchen. Bisschen
ich glaube, aber das liegt halt daran, dass die Leute,
die darüber entscheiden,
halt auch genau die Leute sind, die es betrifft.
Es ist ein bisschen wie mit der Krankenkasse.
Es wird ja seit Jahrzehnten
eigentlich schon gesagt, ey, dass so wie das
oder so, ja, seit ich sehe, so wie
das jetzt mit der Krankenkasse läuft, kann das
nicht, weil mit der Rente ja ähnlich. Aber
gerade mit der Krankenkasse, es wird immer mehr
Zwei-Klassen-Medizin und
die Ärzte sind am Meckern,
die Krankenpfleger, die Krankenhäuser,
die Patienten, alle sitzen. Und man weiß eigentlich,
das kann so nicht weitergehen. Aber das Ding ist halt,
die Leute, die darüber entscheiden,
sind höchstwahrscheinlich privatversichert
und alle Beamte, die das dann
letztendlich durchsetzen, umsetzen und
planen müssen, wenn sich da was ändert, sind ja auch
alle privatversichert. Die juckt das
persönlich alles gar nicht.
Die haben da keinerlei persönliches Interesse dran,
dass sich da irgendwas tut. Ich finde das
auch nicht gut, wie das läuft. Ganz ehrlich.
Ich finde es auch nicht gut, dass man sagt,
dass wir quasi eine immer weiter
auseinandergehende Zwei-Klassen-Medizin in Deutschland
haben. Und ich finde es auch nicht gut,
wie das, ja, wie man
behandelt wird als gesetzlich Versicherter
bei vielen Ärzten. Kannst du ja teilweise echt vergessen.
Also erstens hast du teilweise übelste Probleme,
Termine zu kriegen.
Und die Behandlung ist dann halt auch für den Arsch.
Oftmals.
Das wird dann einfach so, ah, hier machen sie und da,
hier und da, nehmen sie nochmal ein paar Pillen und so.
Da wird den Leuten gar nicht mehr richtig zugehört.
Das ist auch der Grund, warum ich mich privatversichern lasse.
Jetzt mit kurz vor
40. Also jetzt bin ich 40,
aber dann, ja, zählt man halt.
Kurz vor 41
zähle ich dann ab nächstem Jahr.
Mit 40. 40 ist das letzte, wo man sagt, ey,
kann man noch machen. Ist auch der Grund.
Weil ich keinen Bock mehr auf den Scheiß hab.
Ich hätte das nicht gemacht,
wenn das Aussicht auf Besserung gehabt hätte.
Als würde es das
in irgendeiner Art und Weise
verbessern ohne grundlegende Änderung.
Es ist doch erst so scheiße geworden.
Zahlt zu viel mehr.
Aktuell bezahle ich sogar weniger, aber man
darf sich nicht der Illusion hingeben,
dass das langfristig billiger wäre.
Ist es nicht. Spätestens wenn du in Rente gehst,
weil wenn du in Rente gehst, fallen natürlich ein paar Sachen weg.
Du musst die Pflegeversicherung nicht mehr bezahlen,
du musst die Rückstände, die Rücklagen, Bildungssachen nicht mehr bezahlen.
Es wird ein bisschen billiger, aber
insgesamt wirst du schon mehr bezahlen.
Es sind ja so viele Leute
abgehauen, gerade Leute, die es sich leisten können,
weil es einfach sackt, gesetzlich versichert zu sein.
Von
der Behandlungsqualität,
von der Terminvergabe.
Ich war da überhaupt nie scharf drauf.
Ich wollte mich nie großartig privat versichern.
Aber es ist die letzten Jahre
immer schlechter geworden.
Es ist immer schlechter geworden.
Und wenn du teilweise ein halbes Jahr warten musst
auf einen
Hautarzttermin,
dann bist du entweder an deiner Sache schon verreckt
oder es ist nichts Schlimmes.
Und da habe ich einfach keinen Bock drauf.
Korrekt, das habe ich auch
eine Weile gemacht. Ich habe auch bei manchen Sachen,
wo ich gesagt habe, es muss ein bisschen schneller gehen,
habe ich auch gesagt,
ich bezahle es selbst, dann geht es auch schneller.
Deswegen habe ich mir gedacht, ey, warum sollte ich
ich bezahle den maximalen Betrag
für die gesetzliche Krankenversicherung.
Du gehst nicht ins Krankenhaus,
weil du, keine Ahnung,
hier
einen Pickel
am Hals hast, der
juckt.
Da gehst du nicht ins Krankenhaus, aber
wenn du einen Pickel am Hals hast, der juckt,
das kann sich natürlich in einem halben Jahr auch in etwas Schlimmeres entwickelt haben,
oder eben nicht, und es ist dann weg.
Und wenn du denkst,
es ist etwas Schlimmes, naja, also ich sage mal so,
wenn du halt irgendwie etwas hast, was dir aussieht, als könnte es sich entzünden,
aber deswegen rennst du halt nicht,
du rennst ins Krankenhaus, gehst da eigentlich nur,
wenn du etwas Akutes hast. Was Akutes, wo du denkst,
es könnte jetzt unmittelbar lebensbedrohlich sein.
Du denkst,
beim Krieger, Schlaganfall,
Herzinfarkt,
wobei das ja im Prinzip alles
das Gleiche ist, egal ob Schlaganfall,
Herzinfarkt,
vergessen, wie das bei der Lunge heißt,
oder irgendwelche
Thrombose und so, das ist ja im Prinzip alles der gleiche
Auslöser.
Irgendwas verstopft deine Adern,
und
je nachdem, wo das passiert,
hat das halt unterschiedliche Auswirkungen.
Letztendlich ist es ja
die gleiche Ursache oftmals,
ja, und
bei sowas, klar, ins Krankenhaus,
ja, aber es wäre halt
schön, wenn du irgendwas hast, wenn du
irgendwie, was weiß ich, einen Pickel am Hals,
sieht so aus, als könnte es sich entzünden, entzünde sich,
wenn du schneller zum Hautarzt könntest, als ein halbes Jahr.
Und ich hab das gesehen, vor ein paar Jahren,
da hatte ich nix,
hatte ich auch sowas, aber nix Schlimmes hat sich rausgestellt,
ja,
ich hab bei meinem Hautarzt angerufen,
hab gesagt, hier, ich hab da so, ich weiß nicht,
hier so ein Hals, so ein Pickel,
ist auch irgendwie so ein bisschen,
ist auch irgendwie rot, und tut weh,
und da hat jemand gesagt, ja, ein halbes Jahr,
ein halbes Jahr kann ich vorbeikommen, hab ich auch gesagt, okay,
im halben Jahr hat sich das
entweder durch meinen Hals gefressen, und ich bin tot,
oder es ist nix Schlimmes.
Also, was hab ich gemacht?
Bei einem anderen Hautarzt angerufen,
in Frankfurt, wo ich von der Arbeit ohne Probleme
hingehen konnte, hab gesagt, hier, Jungs,
bezahl das selbst, ja, wie sieht's aus,
reicht's Ihnen morgen noch?
Ja, kein Thema, bin ich morgen hin,
hat die sich angeguckt, hat gemeint, nee, ist
nix Schlimmes, aber cremen sie das mal
hier regelmäßig, regelmäßig ein,
hat sich ein bisschen entzündet, hab ich
wahrscheinlich zu viel dran rumgepult mit den Fingern,
und jetzt wieder alles gut.
Ist halt schon kacke,
ne? Ja, also,
letztendlich, wer da wie dran schuld ist, will ich
gar nicht sagen, es ist ein Prinzip,
was unterm Strich rauskommt,
ist, dass die Behandlungsqualität
zackt, oftmals, und
dass auch die Geschwindigkeit, wie du da
Termine kriegst, zackt.
Ist halt für den Arsch, ja.
Und das war so schlecht, das hat sich so
hat sich so in Schlechte entwickelt,
die letzten paar Jahre, dass ich jetzt gesagt hab,
ich lass mich jetzt noch privat versichern,
jetzt, ich hab keine Vorerkrankung, ja,
noch, weiß ja nie, ich mein, ich bin jetzt 40,
weiß ja nie, was da noch alles passieren kann,
keine Vorerkrankung, hab nix Schlimmes
irgendwie, hatte die letzten
Jahre über, außer
bisschen Erkältung und Husten, auch nix,
also, ich bin da ein guter Kandidat für.
Ich finde auch nicht gut, dass es so ist,
aber es ist halt leider so. Was willst du
machen, ne? Kannst du jetzt, kannst du ja
letztendlich, das ist das, was ich sage, es ist leider
so, dass echt, das einzige, was du
machen kannst, aktuell, hier ist,
was heißt hier so, allgemein, dass du
guckst, dass du selbst möglichst gut
für dich aufgestellt bist.
Was du das Beste draus machst, aus deinen
Möglichkeiten. Du selbst.
Weil du dich absolut
nicht darauf verlassen kannst, dass irgendjemand
anderes jemals was für dich macht. So sad,
so sadge das ist.
Deswegen hab ich mich jetzt auch dazu entschieden,
das zu machen. Ich mein, ich verdien genug Kohle,
ich kann das langfristig
mir auch leisten, und
ich war einfach null damit
zufrieden, wie das läuft.
Ich hab keinen Bock, zum Arzt
gehen zu müssen und betteln, dass sie mich behandeln.
Seh ich nicht ein. Und der
Unterschied, ich hab's ja ein paar Mal
verglichen, der Unterschied zwischen
ähm, ich bezahl
selbst, oder ich geh
ähm,
ich geh mit meiner
Versichertenkarte hin, der Unterschied ist halt enorm.
Nicht nur die Wartezeit, sondern auch die Behandlungsqualität.
Enorm. Ich konnt's ja vergleichen,
mehrfach schon. Das
dachte ich mir, wenn ich den Kram eh bezahle,
jetzt schon selbst manchmal,
dann kann ich mich auch gleich privat versichern lassen.
Dann muss ich nicht diesen
Batzen bezahlen,
den ich bezahlen muss, ich bezahle
den Höchstbetrag, den's gibt für die gesetzliche
Krankenversicherung, plus
nochmal ab und zu Behandlung, dann kann ich mich auch gleich
privat versichern lassen.
Umgehst du nicht in ein anderes Land? Naja, weil ich
zu faul bin.
Weil ich zu bequem bin und zu faul
bin. Ich bin zu faul,
zu bequem, und ich hab hier halt auch zu viel
Zeug, ja. Ich hab hier meinen
Job, ich hab das Haus,
paar Leute, die ich kenn,
ja, im Prinzip könnte man sagen, weil ich zu faul und
zu bequem bin. Aber man darf
sich auch nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass das jetzt
auf der anderen Seite alles immer so viel
besser ist. Ah, da hast du andere
Probleme. Ich brauch keine Hilfe.
Ich, äh, bin bei mir schon alles
durch mittlerweile. So, gucken
ob's mittlerweile Updates gibt.
Oh, irgendwas, was
ich noch nie gehört hab, wird geupdatet. Nice.
Weiß ich nicht.
Keine Ahnung. Kann ich
dir nicht sagen,
in welchem Land es besser läuft. Ich weiß nur,
dass es nicht zu meiner Zufriedenstellung
gelaufen ist, bisher.
Das stimmt, das ist echt nicht schlecht, aber
Online-Doc sieht man das auch ganz extrem.
Wenn du da Termine
buchen willst, du
kreuzt an, privat versichert,
kriegst du nächste Woche einen Termin,
oder diese Woche, kreuzt du an,
ähm, gesetzlich versichert
war das so drei Monate.
Nehmen wir doch mal irgendwas, nehmen wir doch mal
beispielsweise irgendwas, so keine Ahnung,
äh,
keine Ahnung, ähm,
sagt mir mal irgendwas.
Was, was, was, was wollen wir machen? Ähm,
MRT.
Okay, Chat sagt MRT.
MRT in München, okay?
MRT in München.
So. Wie heißt das?
DocLib oder so, DocTolib?
Okay.
MRT.
MRT in München. Alles klar.
So. Äh,
Verfügbarkeiten,
Filter entfernen, okay.
So, Radiologie München.
Nehmen wir mal irgendwie radiologische
Zentrum.
Okay, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal den.
Keine Ahnung. So, und jetzt sagt man hier, ich will
einen Termin buchen.
Äh, okay.
Termin, das ist aber so ein,
so ein radiologisches Zentrum,
das ist immer schwierig, da gibt's, da gibt's
oftmals was. Okay, Termin buchen.
Da kann man doch nicht mal auswählen,
was man, was man, äh, wie man
versichert ist. Ja, bei solchen Zentren geht das immer relativ
schnell, das war ein schlechtes Beispiel.
MRT ist was, das, das, das geht mal.
So, und wenn du hier auswählst.
Wie kannst du denn da mal auswählen,
ob privat oder gesetzlich? Ist komisch,
ne? Weiß auch nicht. Keine Ahnung. Dann,
dann gehen wir mal hier, keine Ahnung, München,
so, und dann wollen wir,
was gibt's denn so? MRT ist
ein blödes Beispiel, eigentlich geht das meistens Schlag auf
Schlag. Wir brauchen hier, ich weiß was,
Kardiologe. Kardiologe. Ja,
Leute, die irgendwie Kreislaufprobleme haben.
So. Ja.
Das ist, das ist ein schönes Beispiel. Wir können auch
Hautarzt, das ist ein schönes Beispiel, ja.
Okay, bei dem hier geht's schneller.
So, jetzt
gucken wir mal, ob wir hier auswählen können, privat
oder, okay,
Alter, okay, Alter, was hat der,
der, der ist ja krass ausgebucht, der Typ.
Okay, nehmen wir mal,
nehmen wir mal hier ihn, siebter, siebter November.
Okay, okay, Termin buchen.
Nein.
Vor Ort.
Okay, privat versichert, äh,
Untersuchungstermin, äh,
pff,
keine Ahnung.
Keine Ahnung.
Erst vor Ort, erste Untersuchung, Neupatient.
Okay, siebter November.
Äh, vor Ort, gesetzlich
versichert,
Untersuchungstermin, erste Untersuchung, Neupatient.
Okay, nice,
in München ist wohl alles gut.
Ich hab nix gesagt, in München scheint
die, in München ist die Welt noch in Ordnung.
In München scheint's zu funktionieren,
ja. Also da, ich
hab andere Erfahrungen gemacht, gerade beim Thema
Hautarzt, ähm, Hanno war ich schon
lange nicht mehr, Hautarzt.
Hautarzt hat ewig gedauert.
Machen wir doch mal, machen wir doch mal Just for Funny.
Komm, das probieren wir jetzt noch mal.
Doglip, machen wir mal hier, Hanau,
Hanau,
Hautarzt.
Gibt's nicht so viele.
Deswegen geh ich auch nicht mal nach Hanau zum
Hautarzt.
Oh, keine Ahnung, nehmen wir einfach mal den
ersten. Nehmen wir mal den
erstbesten. 15. April
2025.
Privatversichert?
31. Oktober.
Tja, geht ein bisschen
schneller, hä? Gesetzlich versichert,
Sprechstunde, 15. April
2025. Genau, das
ist die Erfahrung, die ich unter anderem auch gemacht hab.
Ja. Und das ist halt schon
ein Unterschied, ne?
Halbes Jahr warten oder in ner Woche.
Genau
diese Erfahrung hab ich auch damit gemacht.
Und nicht nur, nicht
nur mit dem Hautarzt.
Wo ich halt auch gesagt hab, nee, nee.
Kein Bock. Weil ich geh jetzt
was futtern.
Trickfrage, was gibt's
heute zu essen? Ihr denkt
alle, ihr wisst's.
Aber ihr wisst das nicht.
Nudeln mit Lachs? Falsch. Heute gibt's
ein halbes Hähnchen.
Ich weiß, Nudeln mit Lachs sind eigentlich dran.
Aber heute gibt's das
restliche halbe Hähnchen. Außer
planmäßig, ja?
Nee, nee, Bolognese gab's
letzte Woche. Halbes Hähnchen
gibt's. Ok, Leute.
Ich geh jetzt
was futtern. Wir hören uns.
Die Züge funktionieren in der Schweiz auch.
Das hab ich auch schon gehört.
Nee, das reicht nicht als Grund.
Also wenn du für mich
ein Haus und einen guten Job
in der Schweiz hast, dann können wir mal drüber reden.
Aber ansonsten seh ich das nicht auf,
hier einfach alles stehen und liegen zu lassen.
Diese Annehmlichkeiten
aufzugeben.
Bis denn, Leute. Macht's gut.
See you.